Don't,
don't,
don't what happened.
But this was a heterosexual top 40 song
and then all of a sudden who said my
Dick,
who said that?
What happened?
I apologize that just popped out.
No Pun intended.
You fuck you feel if the animals,
he's back from Italy.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I'm back from the south of France.
Man.
We both went to Europe.
Very cultured,
very close.
Drink wine over there.
Of course I did.
Did you what you did you contact the
symbol?
Yay.
And then just let him know how much you
know.
No,
I didn't need to,
cause I was with a very rich friends.
It,
we just,
I just throw a dart at a cellar and I
took how insanely good wines.
I like one of those,
Oh forget it.
I was like,
I was saying shit like this.
oh I smelled nutmeg and pencil
cause that's what I've heard people say.
They get mad at you and you.
Of course,
they came after me and then I took a,
then I sit some white wine.
I went,
whoa.
I feel like I just got hit in the head
with by a farmer.
I love saying dumb shit like that to try
and do a wine tasting bars,
like one of those,
those parties where they all get around
and they all talk about it.
How,
you know what I heard Smia say you trust
me on this one.
I said,
why?
Because he,
I was going to order our white whining.
It's unique.
I said,
well,
describe it.
He goes,
it's like biting into a wet dog.
I'll say,
hey,
that's exactly what I feel like
he was telling you that it's good.
Yeah.
It's like getting,
getting biting into a wet dog.
People.
He's done.
Shane.
I'd like good wine.
It tastes good.
I like that.
Yeah.
There's a part of me that rejects the
fucking,
the nonsense so hard.
Well,
it shouldn't anything as well.
It should.
You should always reject that horse
shit,
but it sits.
It's so fucking pretentious.
Of course,
it's pretentious.
Think most pretentious here,
these,
the here,
the way they describe it,
it really holds you a pallet prison.
It holds your palate prisoner.
But here's the good news in a velvet
casing.
Oh,
speaking of velvet casings,
I was at a restaurant once,
a very fun restaurant and fairphone
Italian restaurant,
and a gentleman walked in with a
briefcase with two bottles of wine and
velvet in the briefcase.
I had to resist the chimpanzee urge to
over the table and smashed him in his
fucking head with that case.
But here's the thing,
here's the thing about that.
Here's the thing,
and here's the reason I support him
because I'm such a freak for one.
You cannot send $1,000 bottle of wine.
Uh,
you can't ship it because a lot of times
they put it in the hall of a ship and it
comes through,
say the Suez Canal gets hyper.
Yeah,
it might be 150 degrees in that hall.
Not Good.
And it's below or above the waterline.
You're in trouble.
So they fly that wine,
you can be fucked.
Yeah,
you it.
But this guy,
he just was bringing it to a restaurant,
kind of a dick.
This is kind of,
it's kind of a weird move.
And You bring your own food to a
restaurant.
I mean,
I guess it's a drink,
but it's not like you bring your own
tomatoes.
Excuse me.
Could you tell the chef to chop these
tomatoes?
Yeah,
a parallel with the floor.
I've never brought my own one.
I tell him it's,
it's obnoxious.
The establishment.
Yeah,
it's weird.
it is weird.
And then they have a corkage fee.
They charge you to open your won $35
that's fairly reasonable.
Well,
it's just if you're bringing $1,000
bottle of wine,
you know,
but I don't understand why one wine,
I do understand,
but I don't understand why someone is
willing to pay.
But I do understand it.
I do.
Because you want to be a part of that
fuck head club.
Well,
if you're,
and if you're a freak,
like man,
you like wine on that level when you
really pay attention it for me,
I actually,
it's,
I didn't even know how to describe it.
It's literally an experience,
right?
I tell you.
So my buddy,
I went to see who's made more money than
God and this is why he's,
I don't know if I told you this,
so all the money,
you know what I mean?
He has as much money as bruce
springsteen almost and a probably.
And uh,
he,
uh,
super rich and he,
I told you that he said,
we're going to open this,
this wine that Robert Parker gave a
hundred out of a hundred and called it
one of the wines of the century.
Who is Robert Park?
Robert Parker is the critic who sets the
standard.
There are a lot of eat that,
you know that,
yeah,
I know.
I'm terrible.
Really bothers me.
I know,
but when you see an RP Robert Parker and
it has a 93,
94,
five,
you're paying a lot of money.
I want to hang out with Robert Parker.
Well,
he's a guy,
I think he's from Maryland and he's an
American dude and he's got his taste.
It doesn't mean he's right.
It just means he knows wine and he set
the standard.
Now there are more people,
but for the most part when Robert Park
gives your wine and 95 or above God,
why I hit him with a brick.
Hey,
hey.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Did you think he says snarky things when
you go to dinner with him?
Well he,
he'll say for example the one I was
drinking,
he called it a century and one,
one of the wines of the century.
So don't try to please don't try to buy
it because you know you can't find it.
Is he the Tony Hawk of wine connoisseurs
as he is because nobody knows anyone
that's gates other than Tony Hawk.
That's,
that's actually,
that's exactly what he is.
That's exactly what it is.
And the Lance Armstrong of wine.
Yes.
And there are people who are trying to
make their way and,
and real critics,
but for the most part he's still the
man.
How much does it Piss people off?
Who,
who ride bikes,
who like are really good and no one
gives a fuck about them cause there's
not Lance Armstrong,
there's one guy,
there was Greg Lamont for awhile.
I remember he was also an American.
We remember him,
but you know,
nobody,
nobody.
I think part of it's also because he was
an American and so dominant and I'm,
and it's not,
you know,
Americans don't watch bike racing.
I could never stand on the sideline and
be like,
how long aisles keep on him.
I must keep bundling.
You know,
here's a water one,
an orange.
I'm not that guy.
Life is too short to watch a fucking
bike.
Race is definitely too short to be
watching on the sidelines,
like waiting.
It's that.
That's how I feel about marathons,
but Europeans are so different than we
are in that sense.
Would Europeans obsess over Formula One
they obsess over?
That's different than a formula one is
fucking why.
Yeah,
it's wild.
You ever seen those videos?
They do from inside the cockpit of a
Formula One car.
It's crazy,
but there's some old lightening fast
decision making going on there,
but when Senate died,
if you look at the streets of Brazil for
his funeral,
it was something that you would never
see in the United States.
If you have a great race car driver,
like say a great nascar driver,
you wouldn't see,
I think it was some crazy number of
people that showed up in the streets of
Brazil.
Well,
the Brazilians are insanely
nationalistic.
They love their country.
They're very,
very patriotic.
So when someone comes along like Sena
who dominates something that's
traditionally a European dominated
sport,
like Formula One,
and he was a wild man,
you said a documentary on him.
I didn't there.
Look at that funeral.
Wow.
Look at that.
And he was,
uh,
you know,
he was the guy who,
who could have been a playboy,
but he never really messed with girls.
He was,
he was,
uh,
a Samurai who's dedicated.
Yeah.
His,
his ability to shave milliseconds,
you know,
and just to take crazy chances and cut
people off and Oh yeah,
Jesus Christ,
that precision.
But that's a,
that is something that,
I don't know anything about it,
but I'm sure when you follow it and that
sort of,
those,
those millimeters,
those differences are what make
everything,
you know,
when you have a cultivated sense,
when you know what you're looking at.
And what looking for it's a,
it must be very enjoyable.
Well,
they have a deep connection with how
much traction there is exactly on those
tires feel like they feel it kicking
out.
Like they,
they,
they literally say with race car drivers
that you have to have an educated ass.
Damn.
Really?
Yeah.
Your ass has to be able to feel when
your car is breaking loose.
Like if you are a race car driver and
you had a numb ass,
you'd probably be fucked.
Wow.
Like if you had like Sciatica or
something and asked went numb,
which I would imagine it'd be a real
problem with someone who sits down all
the time.
Yeah.
They're truck drivers,
right?
They get Sciatica or all the time,
but race car drivers itself,
physical,
they lose so much water.
They lose like somebody like seven
pounds of water or something in inner
race.
Oh,
I would imagine the crazy sweat like a
pig.
Yeah.
It's hot as fuck.
They don't have air conditioning in that
thing.
Yeah.
There's giant engine.
They're flying down the road.
Lazy.
Oh,
it's mad.
It's so interesting that you have to
have an educated ass.
Cause I think horseback riding,
if you watch high,
high level jumpers,
they,
you know,
are just Saje guys.
They,
they,
it's the same exact thing.
It's all feel literally it looks like
they're doing nothing.
So the differences between the best in
the world and the number 300 you and I
could never tell the difference because
they don't look like they're doing
anything.
Literally.
They're just,
they look like for me,
they look like they're sitting upright
very still as why I could never ride a
horse and just,
there's nothing going on.
But the details,
those little like where are they placed?
The micro,
how they micromanage that saddle and the
signals they're sending to the horse
with their hands,
their legs and their ass is a whole
different thing.
That's so often the case though with
things.
Would things look effortless because the
people that are awesome at them do it so
smoothly that it just,
you know,
you can't appreciate it unless you,
you actually do it.
That's what I love about life.
That's literally what I love about,
you know,
and it sounds silly,
but you can touch a little of that in
anything you do when you,
um,
you know,
when you practice something you're not
good at.
So tennis,
I always talking about tennis unboxing.
Am I good at boxing and tennis?
No.
Do I obsess over where my feet are?
Do I have cess over my grip with the
right,
it's,
I swear to God the actual,
maybe the actual activity is secondary
to how I love to work on the little
details and get better through daily
attendance through daily practice
because something happens to me that
reaches beyond that sport.
So when I do something that I'm maybe a
little afraid of or maybe I'm not good
at,
it forces me to think in a way that
informs the other things in my life that
I make a living at.
I do better at Standup,
I write better when I pushed myself in
these other areas.
It's really interesting.
Yeah,
it totally makes sense because I think
very difficult endeavors.
You know,
whatever,
whatever it is that you're trying to do.
Any fucking dance.
Yeah.
If you were trying to be a ballerina,
which I am.
Are you?
Yeah,
keep calling.
I thought you were done with that.
[inaudible] Bella is my foundation,
but I'm so passionate.
I live,
there's too much a quatre in me.
I live in my groin,
so I had to move to southside Madang.
Well,
people that get really get into Jujitsu
say that as well for has been saying
that a lot.
But you know,
getting into it is to him it's a lot
like writing in some ways or it's so,
it's almost like a meditation and it
completely obsessed it.
A Lot,
lot of people that get into Jujitsu
become completely obsessed with it too.
And it's for those same reasons.
Like you get obsessed,
first of all,
with how deep the rabbit hole goes.
Yes.
That's probably the same with tennis or
with golf.
It's most certainly the same.
I've never played golf,
but I know the people that exactly the
same thing I talked to will jerky will
durkee,
you know,
uh,
he won,
he took second in the,
uh,
10th planet Jiu Jitsu Tournament over
and in Austin.
He's amazing.
He's a professional poker player as
well.
And he was a d one wrestler,
I think out of Virginia and you know,
watching him,
um,
he lost to a,
uh,
another guy who was really good but,
but just barely.
And when you watch those high level,
high level competition,
black belts,
which I'd never seen the subtlety,
I don't even see what they're doing.
I didn't even see them tapping the guy.
Right.
But he was talking to me about how much
he loves games and why poker and Jujitsu
inform each other.
We know Josh Waitzkin same thing.
Same thing with chess.
Gee,
he's a Jujitsu.
Yeah.
Phenomenal.
If you know him well,
he's trying,
I think he has a school where he teaches
kids how to think.
You can cause it to,
he teaches them how to learn through
martial arts.
Math,
I know martial arts,
music and chess.
I,
and it's all kind of the same.
It's kind of the same thing.
It's kind of why I feel like a lot of
times that I do think there's a place
for self help and you know,
inspiration when you're young.
But after a while,
you know,
just trying to get really good at
something under proper tutelage.
I think we'll teach you all of those
things may be,
but there's a lot of people that just
try to get good at it.
They never get good at it.
That probably would do better if they
had better pathways to think.
Yes,
if they learned how to.
Well,
I think first what someone like Tony
Robins does because I've listened to a
lot of his tapes when I was younger and
what I was all set to make fun of him
because I was trying to write this
parody on him and then I listened to him
and I went,
oh,
this motherfucker knows exactly how my
brain works.
I mean a lot of ways he simplifies and
he has tools that helped.
Helped me
focus my energy and recognize,
recognize certain patterns you recognize
certain unhelpful,
bad.
It's very important.
Is having pathways in your mind like
abandoning negative thoughts,
concentrating on positive ones,
abandoning nonsense,
concentrating.
I mean that's a lot of what traps are
that people fall into like addictive
traps,
whether it's gambling or whatever.
Fill in the blank pornography.
Like I was watching this whole thing of
the day where people were coming out
against pornography and pornography
addiction like,
and they were talking about how harmful
pornography's no,
no,
your fucking mind is harmful.
Pornography's people having sex and sex
is awesome.
So shut up.
There's a great,
there's a dean to that.
Well you can simplify it this way.
There's a dean who said,
I am not interested.
It's,
it's less important what you think.
What I want to know is how you think and
you're talking about methodology.
It's,
it's how it's exactly what you're
saying.
It's how you think about life and how
you think about things.
So you may be a slave to certain
pathways and learning how to reprogram
you are your pathways is a way,
way more important thing.
So it's not so much that it's
pornography that's the enemy.
Yes,
it's,
it's the methodology.
Pornography is just sex.
And by the way,
we're just talking about regular
pornography there.
There's certain pornography that you go,
okay,
what the fuck is that for?
Like,
why does anybody need to see people spit
in people's eyes and come and people's
noses and stuff?
Like there's a lot of really fucked up
pornography,
but I always equate that to like the
same thing was like if you watch a
certain violent movies,
it's almost like they are the product of
the ramping up effect.
Three other violent movie that's come
before them.
They've had to go further and further
and further to the point where it's just
totally ridiculous.
That's exactly right.
It's not entertaining.
It's not good.
It's just there.
It's a response to like taking it to the
next level.
The guy who wrote the double helix,
quote unquote for the,
for a serial killer,
for the making of a serial killer,
a guy named Richard Walter who's an FBI
profiler,
brilliant guy.
He said that,
um,
serial killers,
we'll typically,
and this is from literally interviewing
20,000,
30,000 prisoners,
uh,
many of whom were murderers,
violent criminals,
and he put together this profile,
which was that serial killers.
Many times start as with fetishes.
They'll start with,
you know,
well a lot of times it can be as
innocuous as rubbing against people in
public places.
Uh,
and then what?
And then you,
you graduate,
then that doesn't do it for you anymore.
And then you have to go into a store and
cut leather jackets with a razor because
you might get caught.
But it's like skin,
all that stuff.
And S and what he said was that you
never,
once you get to one level,
you never can go back.
You have to go forward.
You don't see them go,
all right,
this is too much.
Let me go back to rubbing against people
on will never,
I mean,
don't,
don't some people like,
is there people that are potential
serial killers?
They go,
what the fuck am I doing in my life?
I needed,
I don't know,
Take Yoga.
I don't know.
But I do know that there've been some
studies about how,
uh,
less there are,
I guess a lot of serial killers are
maniacs are doing less of that stuff
because they can,
they can get more of it to a simulated
environment.
Well,
that was the argument that the Japanese
had or some Japanese scholars had about
pornography is a Japanese porn is,
is my might be wrong about this.
That it's more embraced and that when
you look at like deviant behavior,
it's more embraced and films and things
like that.
And that sort of keeps him from doing it
in real life.
Yeah.
I would imagine that you can get
satiated visually.
You have those,
those visual triggers,
they say that the triggers for fighting,
you know,
when you watch mma,
there are a lot of those visual triggers
for men that are similar to what
pornography does to a man.
When we see two dudes kicking each other
and knocking each other out,
we want to do it.
Yeah.
Or at least we can't take our eyes off
it.
Yeah.
We definitely can't take your eyes off
of it.
Um,
but I think that also it's possible that
that could work.
If they say that about video games,
like the argument against video games,
it's always been the video games
encourage violence,
but it shows the,
the actual facts show that's the
opposite is true.
That video games actually get people
involved in the violence of video games
and it satisfies whatever weird cravings
people might have for violence,
which are,
you know,
leftover from thousands and thousands of
years of DNA of people being successful
in violence,
being rewarded for it.
You violence was a way you survived.
You know,
think about hunting while the coliseum,
man,
I went to the coliseum this week been,
oh my God,
that is a fucking trip.
First of all,
I did not know that the coliseum
literally means next to the Colossus.
I didn't know that it was all about,
there was a gigantic,
I think it was 150 foot high bronze
statue of Nero that he had constructed.
Well,
you know,
the entire colosseum was Niro's house at
one point in time.
It didn't exist.
It was like,
there's like seven areas of Rome,
like seven hills of Rome or something
like that.
And His
fucking house was three of them.
Damn.
His house had an enormous,
I think it was like more than a hundred
acre lake in the backyard of his house.
A man made lake.
Wow.
And that manmade lake like to drain it,
the drainage system to build that lake
there.
They,
they're just discovering some of the
areas of the coliseum today.
So what they did is when they tore down
his house,
they built the coliseum for the people.
And it was like one of the biggest
public buildings ever.
And they built it to satisfy the people
that were just fucking furious that this
cunt,
yeah.
Taken over,
burned Rome.
He was just insane.
I mean,
Nero was just fucking completely insane.
But what they had done with his,
his structure was turned it into this
call scene,
but it was right next to this enormous
statue of him.
So when you say like the La Coliseum,
that's a stupid name,
right?
Because the La next to the call next
colossus,
that does not make any sense.
But that's what coliseum means.
Right?
It's wild.
When you go to Italy and especially
Rome,
and you're standing and structures that
have been there for an,
and we're living and had people died on
that.
It's kind of like the idea,
the original octagon,
you know?
Well,
way more fucked up than me.
Yeah.
Here's one of the things they found out
just recently,
like really recently that they had boat
fights.
They would fill the bottom of the
coliseum with water.
Wow.
And they would have boats,
Jesus and they would get them.
They've literally just discovered this.
They discovered some sort of a,
um,
some sort of artwork or something,
some writing that indicated that these
boat fights took place for a very short
amount of time,
like a couple of years.
He do that fight each other with your
oars.
They bowels,
they would have battles.
Here it is.
They,
this,
they would fill up powerful Jamie.
They would fill up the bottom with two
meters of water,
six feet of water and have these boats
and float these boats around and they
would fight to the death on boats.
How the fuck would they do that?
I guess the walls kept the water,
I guess they'd say drain it.
Well they had a very complex drainage
system.
Like they showed the draining system to
us,
wouldn't new they take you on a tour,
you know,
and uh,
they were showing us the drainage system
and also the system of raising the wild
animals from the basement up through the
floor.
Yeah.
How would they do that?
They had this thing where these,
uh,
they had a reenactment or,
or recreation of one that a,
I took some photos of,
I put one of the photos on my instagram
and these wild animals would be a locked
in these rooms,
right.
The small rooms,
they would give them no food,
no water,
and they'd keep them there for days.
So they'd be freaking out and starving.
And then finally they'd take them out of
the dark.
They put them,
uh,
they forced them into this platform.
And then they would have these slaves
crank this mechanism that would lift the
platform up through a trap door in the
floor.
So their first light in days,
and they would be out there with these
gladiators and a little and the bottom
floor,
like they had several levels.
And the bottom level was all the rich
people,
but they fucked up and they didn't have
the walls high enough.
So the lions with leap 12 feet over the
wall and just Jack,
all these rich people,
she's just fine.
She's
now the wall thing and though I,
Yay.
Yeah.
So it's something that San Francisco
soon,
that tiger jumped that 12 foot wall.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Well they had to figure out how to do it
too,
because they would get these animals in
there and most of the time they'd let
the animals out and that animals would
be just fucking scared.
They didn't want to fight.
Yeah.
So they,
they realized that by keeping them down
there with no food and no water and
getting them to a complete state of
desperation and hysteria,
that would allow them to ensure that
when they pop that trap door,
the lions would come out and just try to
jack people.
Brutal.
Yeah.
They would kill everything.
They had elephants,
they had all,
all sorts of crazy fucking animals they
had brought in from Africa,
which by the way is not even a thousand
miles away.
I had no idea.
Africa was so close to the ceiling.
You can see it.
You can,
you know what I think?
Well,
you can see,
you can see Africa from Sicily.
I believe.
You can see Africa from there.
You can see it.
Yeah.
Like I'm clear days.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Correct.
Doesn't mean wrong.
It seems like too many miles.
No.
There are certain parts of,
let me look at a map.
I can't remember what it seems like.
What?
Just one area you can see from Spain.
From the tempest main maybe.
Hmm.
I think I can't eat either way,
but kind of crazy.
That was in Spain and says,
you can't get there.
You see the mountains or something?
Yeah.
Wow.
That's crazy.
So crazy.
Is that that?
That's that class.
It is.
Yeah.
Look close to this.
Wow.
It's really close.
Yeah.
Seriously.
It's not attached,
but I don't know why that happened.
Why didn't have it attach?
It's really weird.
That's a shitty map.
Yeah.
Oh,
what?
Yeah,
that's Africa.
Yeah.
You can see that close.
No wonder the Moore's concord system.
Exactly.
They're right there.
Exactly like they traveled.
No,
they got in a fucking raph floated over.
They backstroke turn out the way.
I mean Jack Jacked everybody,
but uh,
it's fucking beautiful.
It's so beautiful,
man.
Oh yeah.
God Damn often coast.
That's where we went.
We went there too.
We did a,
the Mafia coast with the Vatican,
the Vatican's and saying,
did you do the Vatican I did is insane.
And most of all the seven wonders,
man,
the fact that you're walking around on
this fucking tile that's 1700 years old,
it's incredible.
And in all hearts Zayic yeah.
And I mean beautiful artwork that
everybody's walking on.
Yeah.
Like the guy was explaining to us,
they'll like,
this is a 17 year,
a hundred year old work of art.
Not only that,
it was moved from somewhere else and
reconstructed hundreds of years ago
inside the Vatican wasn't even
originally there.
Damn.
I,
I never ever,
I've been to Saint Peter's Cathedral,
I dunno,
maybe
10 times because my uncle used to live
there and he had a rent controlled
apartment over the peanuts in Nevada,
which is really the uncle used to live
in Rome.
Yes.
My uncle,
my uncle was,
uh,
in,
in Brooklyn,
New York,
in Bensonhurst,
New York.
My uncle was a gay man.
Uh,
well he was very handsome.
He was a diver and a,
yeah.
And he was a,
but of course he was an actor and a
singer and a dancer.
And of course in Benson,
hers,
you know,
in Bensonhurst,
Brooklyn in the,
I dunno,
let's call it the what,
uh,
50s,
30s,
forties.
When you were gay,
you know,
it wasn't,
first of all,
you were very Catholic.
So that was already a sin.
Second of all,
you weren't really that welcome.
There wasn't a whole lot of gay pride.
Everybody wanted March.
Uh,
so he went to Italy.
We went to Rome and lived there,
knew he could be accepted.
Well,
he found his little niche.
He got into the theater company there
and I spoke Italian of course,
and a head of Horus and lived for,
and he died at 96 and lived above the
Piazza Navona in a rent controlled
penthouses die from that.
The Vatican own.
He didn't die.
No,
sir.
I'm going to ask you to be a little more
mature.
We have a lot of people listening.
He did not die from dicks.
Uh,
but he was a,
he was a character man and he did lots
of plays.
And did you know that the Vatican owns
the building that houses Europe's
largest gay gathpath house?
I did not know that.
But I also don't believe you because
the,
is that a,
is that a matter of,
uh,
is that a matter of a conjecture or it's
fact.
It's probably a bath house now.
It's the largest gay bath house in
Europe and the Vatican owns it.
Not only that,
I see,
I see the,
there's the cardinals or the bishops
who's fucking office is right above the
gay bath house.
Conveniently,
conveniently,
there's a fucking shoot that just
dropped down a lot of property as lube
up their button,
drop down through the floor and look at
this Vatican please.
Landlord to Europe's biggest gay
bathhouse.
Catholic church paid $30 million to
acquire a building that houses a senior.
Will cardinal end a huge gay sauna?
Nothing.
How weird.
It's so weird that,
uh,
I mean,
I don't know why they would want to own
that.
I don't know cause you want to sweat
while you get your Dick Dick work by
strong man hands.
That's all.
Well the amount of artwork that is in
the Vatican,
like if you haven't been there before,
like I was not that excited about going
to the Vatican before went there.
It was like,
well I want to see the coliseum.
Obviously it's like one of the great
wonders of history like that they had
this thing there and that they did this
and then it's also like the ultimate
sign of excess.
You know,
like the,
the one thing that people point to when
they talk about society's falling apart
due to excess as the Romans,
the Romans,
they went crazy.
Like it was also sort of what gave food
to the reformation.
When Martin Luther,
this German Jesuit priest said,
hey man,
all this money that's going to,
you know,
idolatry essentially like building
these incredible statues and these
incredible cathedrals and we're starving
over here.
How about if we just read the Bible,
we just read the Bible.
Then maybe we'll be,
you know,
just is in favor with God as you guys.
And maybe we don't need a hierarchy of
bishops and all these and popes and all
this sort of rank and file that also
needs a salary that's also taking money.
Well,
Martin Luther was also the first guy to
translate the Bible phonetically so that
regular people could read it because
everybody else was like,
no one knew Latin.
They couldn't read Latin.
That's right.
So it was only these priests that we had
to rely on to,
to get the word of God from Martin
Luther was like,
that's ridiculous.
But as luckily Martin Luther,
it had such a high standing in society,
they couldn't kill him.
Right.
They tried.
He had to leave.
He was always on the run.
But you're right.
But it was,
if he was anyone else,
if he wasn't like a very respected high
standing person in society,
they probably would have jacked him a
long time ago.
Yeah.
That there was already,
um,
from an eye,
I can't remember.
I read a lot about it back in the day,
but um,
he was always under threat of that.
He had to essentially,
I think it was in bitten Berg.
And there's this a phrase that people
always associate with Rome called the
vomitorium and uh,
that's not what it sounds like.
Everybody thinks that they got there and
they threw up and then they went back
and eight again.
That's not what they did.
I always thought they did that.
Yeah.
No,
the vomitorium refers to the way they
got people out of the stadium had
nothing to do with the word vomit.
Huh?
It's the way the stadium is structured.
Is this gigantic?
That's a vomitorium is the,
the,
the exit.
So they had all these exits.
They had a bunch of different doors all
throughout the building.
Like if you look at like some images of
the colosseum,
there's all these pathways.
Like you would go,
you know,
30 yards over,
there's another pathway,
30 hours over,
there's another pathway.
And that allowed an efficient way of
getting people see like look at all the
doorways,
see all those doorways all around it.
That that was an efficient method of
getting people out of the stadium.
So they called it a vomitorium.
But like if you look the etymology of
the word,
like look up the,
the origins of the word vomitorium and
what it means in Latin,
but it doesn't have anything to do with
vomit but sounds like it.
So everybody was like,
ah,
they,
they just fucking eight and threw up.
So people like sort of repeated that
over and over and over again.
Let's stick a feather down their throat.
I'm sure someone did that.
I'm sure there was some fat.
Fuck,
that's right now in Los Angeles.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
I just did.
A girl had a problem with that.
So deny vomitorium.
Okay.
Here it was a place which according to
popular misconception,
the ancient Romans were supposed to
vomit it.
That's not true.
Um,
the arch of a series of entrances or
exit pathways and an ancient Roman
amphitheater or theater.
Yeah.
See,
that's what it really means.
So the popular misconception,
the second version of it,
but translate user over time.
What,
what is the origins of the word though?
Like what does that mean?
Vomitorium is the plural noun.
Huh?
That's weird.
That's the plural vomitorium probably,
you know,
it sounds like it's where people would
vomit out of,
right?
Yeah,
but it's not vomit.
That's not,
it's like that's our word.
Yeah,
but that's not like what they would call
it.
Right?
Like you know what I'm saying?
Like our word vomit is puke,
but that's not what they were referring
to when they were calling it a
vomitorium.
It's just one of those weird Latin
things.
But everybody always thinks that
everybody thinks that that's what a
vomitorium was like.
You should imagine if there was a
fucking house that people would go to
throw up and like,
hey,
let's keep going to go to the vomitorium
fucking puke.
Like what kind of assholes eat?
Here's a feather.
But you would call it the puke house.
Like that is so ridiculous.
The puke room,
vomitorium puke room.
The sauna room.
What is the actual,
does it say Jamie?
It says here this tube misinterpret or
where it might have came from the
misinterpretations.
Yeah,
but what is the original?
Was the actual word mean?
Like vomitorium.
It just sounds like this is the
entrance.
Just fourth.
Oh,
to spew forth this beautiful earth and a
wonder if involvement actually came from
that then.
Yeah,
so the original thing was an exit and
then vomit became that.
Ah,
that's interesting.
It's kind of how language happens,
right?
Yeah,
but that's,
well,
it's weird how it happens over thousands
of years.
So things just stuart and warp.
Yeah.
That's how the language is always
changing.
It's always changing.
We're always making up our own
languages.
It's constant.
While we were there,
they had just found some new shit two
days before we were there.
They're constantly finding new path and
passages underneath the coliseum and new
things,
but the amount of work that was done in
completing that building and making
those structures,
it's insane with free labor,
which is why slavery isn't that bad.
Oh,
what?
Wait a minute.
It's interesting that slavery was the
order of the day for most of history,
but when you look at like wage slavery
today,
when you mean there's no slavery today,
but if you can imprison people in a
state of poverty,
right.
And it's not,
not against their will voluntarily.
Right.
You get people hooked on buying things
and you get them hooked on credit.
So they need to work,
they constantly need to work and then
they're in these jobs that are
completely dead end low wage jobs.
They can't go anywhere and then they
perform these menial tasks.
And until we figure out robot that could
do those tasks far better and far more
efficient.
It's not slavery because they can quit
and leave anytime they want.
But in a lot of ways it has the same
effect.
There's a difference.
I think there's a lot of differences.
I mean I'm talking about there's a macro
difference.
Like there's there
an idea that has gained great traction
and cause ideas move really slowly
sometimes.
But there's an idea that has gained
traction in most of the world and even
in parts of the world where it isn't,
they try to defend it as it being so,
and that is the idea of universal human
rights.
Universal human rights was not an idea
that was embraced by most of the world.
Even as far back properly.
You can make the argument as 1940
slavery was alive and well.
Think about this country and it's and
itself,
this country until 1964 was it a where
there was separate but equal the idea
that you had black and white water
fountains,
um,
a brown horse years before that,
which is nothing slavery.
That's right.
And so the idea that,
and of course that had to be defended
along biblical grounds and all these
kind of shotty ideas,
but the idea of,
of universal human rights,
even though the Judaeo Christian ethic
and even Islam talked about sort of
everybody being of the same moral worth
because we're all from the same father,
right?
That's the monotheistic a notion and
where value comes in those religions,
we're all the same as long as you,
you know,
read the Bible and follow these tenants.
But universally human rights is
something a little bit different and
it's a modern concept and um,
that likes a germ theory.
The idea that these things you can't
see,
but you still have to wash your hands or
you can spread bacteria and things like
that.
Those things that move very slowly.
But that is,
I think where you,
are you connecting those?
I'll just talking about how both those
ideas are ideas.
It took a long time to gain traction,
you know,
even though they were good for us and by
law.
But let's stick to,
let's stick to um,
universal human rights.
I think that that idea,
I think that idea is,
is just that mindset and the fact that
you have to defend it as a society is
why there's such a stark difference
between,
I understand what you're saying by being
at bondage to your lifestyle,
to having to make a living because
you've got people who depend on you and
stuff like that.
I don't think that'll ever go away.
But,
um,
there's such a,
there is,
I don't think that'll go with,
could definitely go on saying we
slavery,
I'm optimistic.
But what I'm saying is that there's,
I think when I'm like,
slaves have zero dignity.
Like it in fact there's no somebody one
time as a historian is that there's no
such thing as a slave slave there.
There are people in bondage.
So anybody who is a slave,
you're not a slave,
but you are a person in slavery.
Right.
So,
so it was like he,
he poses the question,
he said,
what did the civil rights movement begin
in this country?
And it was like,
well,
and sell Alabama and the 60s and the
fifth.
No.
I said,
no,
no.
He said the civil rights movement began
the first day that an African American
was brought to this country against his
will.
Any human being doesn't want to be in
bondage.
You are always trying to get out of
And there is that striving for that.
I think we're getting closer to,
I think,
well wait a minute,
that's slavery.
How was that,
the civil rights movement,
this is the first day that someone's
brought to United States against their
will.
That's not the first day that someone
enacted some sort of a civil right.
Well,
he was being,
what he was saying was that,
you know,
everybody is always fighting for dignity
and their own serenity and their own
civil rights regardless of,
you know,
where they are.
If you put someone in bondage and you
make them do things against their will
and you,
you take their dignity away,
they are immediately,
they're immediately beginning to
struggle for their own freedom.
Right,
and that's where the conspiracy theories
fall into play,
where modern capitalism is thought of as
being some sort of a new way around that
that instead of having people slaves,
like literally bonding them,
putting them in chains,
keeping them against their will.
Instead you just set up these honey
traps and you allow people to get sucked
into these things like having massive
debt from student loans and making
credit cards easy and allowing people to
mortgage a house they can't really
afford knowing full well that eventually
the bank's going to foreclose on this
and reap some sort of a profit and that
all these things,
this is where conspiracy theories fall
into play,
that all these things are set up to
enact a modern form of slavery and that
there's always going to be people that
are taking advantage of people below
them and putting them in very
disadvantageous situations for their own
gain.
I would say that that's literally the
state of nature.
And,
and what I mean by that is that,
let,
let's just take for example,
I'm the marketplace.
Uh,
if you just let people,
you let people go,
let people do their thing.
They are going to,
for example,
uh,
there's going to be a marketplace for
differences of opinion.
This is what I mean,
there's a company,
it's about to start up a,
you start a company,
I don't know what it is.
Let's just say it's a,
you know,
a tech gadget.
And you're going to have groups of
people on this side that are going to
say,
that's going to be the next big thing.
Joe Rogan's company's going to be the
next apple and you're going to have a
bunch of other people on the other side.
We're going to go,
you know what,
uh,
not a shot.
And here's why.
So you have these differences of opinion
and there's a marketplace.
There is a marketplace for what
essentially is a derivative,
uh,
you know,
or a swap.
There's a marketplace there too where
people say,
I will bet you I will short that.
I will basically say,
I'll buy it at this price right now and
I'll sell it to,
and if it goes up in value,
you pay me the difference.
That's how,
that's how marketplaces work.
So for me it's capitalism has just a
bunch of people with different opinions
who are trying to make money,
who are coming up with ideas.
And if you create a society where you
can enforce contracts and make people
keep their promises and you can,
you can ensure that people have what's
called property rights,
which is really important.
You know,
courts essentially that have integrity,
that can't be bought off,
then that's as far as I can see what
you'd call a free market capitalist
society.
And it seems to be better than most of
the other sort of,
uh,
systems that require central oversight.
And because I,
not because central oversight is such a
bad thing,
I just think it's impossible to control.
You know,
the way people think on such a macro
scale.
I think it's very,
I don't think you have to control the
way people think well or behave or
behave more harder.
Well,
yeah,
I get it.
And I see what you're saying about
capitalism and I see what you're saying
about society.
I think that all these things,
when we point to ancient room would
point to how fucked up their world was.
And slavery is recently as a couple
hundred years ago.
I think what we're saying is things are
getting better or we're evolving.
We're figuring out a way to make a
society that is more beneficial to more
people,
but still not to everyone.
And then the point is,
is it possible to create a Utopian
society where it's beneficial to
virtually everyone?
And then the way to do that,
the only way to do that is like,
here's a,
here's a good example.
Like people love to tout socialism as
some sort of a cure to what ails us.
You know that somehow or another that if
you get people and you,
you give everybody money and you,
everybody's shares wealth equally.
But the problem with that cuts out
incentive incentive for madness and
excellence and the incentive for madness
and excellence is why you have tesla
motorcars and Ilan Musk and all these
fucking jobs.
Steve Jobs.
Steve jobs is a fucking maniac.
He was up,
I mean probably a bad dad.
Probably.
Probably probably a shitty got to work
for,
you know,
probably a total asshole if you did
something wrong.
If you put a one instead of a zero and a
line of code and the fucking phone
crashed when it hit a thousand emails or
what,
he'd probably beat the fuck out of him.
I mean he's a maniac.
Yeah,
but it was because of him that we have
iphones.
Well it's because of that kind of
madness.
100% how many,
how many iphones have you bought that
were made in Russia?
How many cars have you bought that were
made in rush?
Exactly,
but in Russia's fucked up example,
because it's not really socialism,
it's really communist.
Dictatorship nowadays is,
yeah.
What kind of was and then it wasn't and
it was again,
it never really recovered.
The Russians.
I think that their problem is they have
one idea of power,
which is biggest guns.
Divert your eyes in my presence.
How fucked up is that?
Russia's getting kicked out of the
Olympics.
Yeah,
I pay attention is,
yeah,
of course.
Fuck.
They're going to tick.
Kicked the whole team.
The whole Russian team.
What cheating is so it's so systemic,
so systemic.
It's,
it's state sponsored come.
They've got the KGB apparently are that.
Well,
it used to be the KGB involved.
now I have this one woman who was a
whistle blower who's going to compete
independently without a nation.
How long before they kill her?
I know.
Good luck with that bitch.
Get fucking bottle of water.
That's,
that's Russia's problem.
Russia's idea.
There are two types of power,
right?
There's the power that where you can't
stop staring at somebody because they
have prestige and you want to be like
them.
That's a power that you can use for
good.
If you have all those eyeballs on you,
you can,
you can say,
hey guys,
I know you're all looking at me and you
do this all the time and how many people
love this?
How many people download this podcast?
You're very aware of the responsibility
that comes with,
so you do two things.
Do you try to keep it really honest and
true to yourself?
But you also try to have really smart
people on who have different
perspectives so you can kind of figure
out a way to get those ideas out into
people's heads.
That's one form of power that I would
consider a positive use.
Then there's the Russian model of power.
Well,
it's not power.
It's influence.
Uh,
I would,
I think they're very closely related.
I think they're joined at the hill.
They don't,
it doesn't control anyone.
That's the difference between like the
power that Putin has and the power that
the nerdist so,
so,
so.
Exactly.
You just use the word.
So there's a difference.
So there's power that controls when
there's power that inspires.
And I think power that inspires is what
this country needs to keep in mind at
all times.
That's the power look.
You always need power,
you need guns and stuff.
They're crazy people.
You need a strong military.
I think the difference is like is it
using a blanket statement like power?
It's like the board drugs,
like caffeine is drug,
so it was meth.
You know what I mean?
Like there's power and then there's
influence,
but there's things that are powerful and
then there's things that have power over
people and exactly like to control
people like and then people can't do
anything about it.
That's exactly,
that's a difference.
That's right.
So the word power,
the problem is the use of the word
power.
I remember also mindset.
I believe that Russia and which is such
an amazing,
with such an amazing group of people,
they could do anything they wanted and a
strong culture,
but I think the mindset of Russians in
many,
in many ways,
maybe it's not their fault,
maybe it's a product of their history.
Their mindset is that they admire the,
the first example of power control and
strength and dominance more than they
admire the power that influences and
inspires things that are powerful.
So I like trump supporters.
I think so they're polluting supporters.
They like a strong man at the helm.
We know that trump like Putin and Putin
likes trump.
Yes,
that sec.
Yeah,
it's probably not good,
right?
I would imagine.
No,
I haven't been paying attention to the
Republican national convention,
but shit,
but Jamie did and I,
but I am paying attention to the fact
that this is,
this is what I like about all this
stuff.
What I like about all this trump
nonsenses it's shown how vulnerable the
system is to fuckery that a madman and
come along and just take over the whole
thing.
Did you see what his fucking biographer
said?
That guy,
he had rosie for Morris,
right?
Deep remorse.
And he said that if Donald Trump becomes
president and it has the key to the
nuclear football,
he said he literally could be the end of
civilization.
He said,
the book should have been titled and
styled titled instead of the art of the
deal,
should
have been titled the art of Sociopath,
I believe.
Or,
or the,
the words of a sociopath or something
along those lines.
But his take on trump is that he's a
total sociopath.
Not Surprising to me.
I mean,
he's certainly a narcissist and maybe
they're the same thing in some ways,
but I've,
I mean,
my wife though,
he's,
he's got a hot wife.
He's always bringing things back to
himself and he just,
he just lies at his convenience.
He's just,
it's unbelievable.
Do you know that he's been sued?
Something like 3,500 times?
I believe that when you have a huge
company,
that happens a lot.
So that's,
that's,
that's not as surprising to me.
What my,
by waiters and stuff.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
his creditors,
a lot of people that invested,
you know,
people that did work for him never got
paid.
A lot of the companies that he started a
went bankrupt.
You know,
we talked about how the university,
well,
yeah,
we talk about him being this great
businessman.
I don't know that we have a lot of
evidence.
He's done a good job creating a brand
that's worth something.
So if you put it on a hotel,
it comes with in your mind,
uh,
you think of high quality prestige plus,
you know,
nice bedding and the,
the,
or if he has a building,
it's the trump tower.
Also interesting that he took the name
trump because like I believe trump card,
that expression trump card was there
before the name trump because his last
name is drunk.
Yeah,
drunk.
That's his actual last name that I saw.
John all ever her.
Talk about that.
It's real nice.
I mean there's nothing wrong with that
named [inaudible].
I mean,
shit,
Arnold Schwarzenegger became famous as
Arnold Swartz,
a nigger.
I mean,
he's got the goofy,
his fucking name ever and he smashed it
with that name in America.
You can get away with it.
Why couldn't you be drunk?
I did the wrong with drum.
I remember it doesn't mean anything.
I remember being amazed that the United
States voted a man by the name of Barack
Hussein Obama.
And when we are public enemy number one
was uh,
you know,
uh,
Osama bin Ladin so phonetically they
sound very similar.
Oh yeah.
Well how about who's sane when we were
also Emma enemies with [inaudible]
saying exact crazy.
Yeah.
I mean he had a goofy ass fucking name
for a guy to be elected president,
but that's why I give Americans a lot of
credit.
I think Americans are,
are,
you know,
if you listened to European stock,
but they're always marveling at how
quote unquote dumb Americans are.
I don't think Americans are dumb.
And I think Americans and a lot of ways
they're very fair minded too.
Well,
there's that,
but there's also the fact that there's a
two party system where if you are on the
left,
you have to support whoever's on the
left.
That's why all these people lining up to
support Hillary Clinton and ignoring
left and right.
All the crazy evidence against her just
being completely full of shit.
She's corrupt.
We,
oh my God.
We played this video the other day where
they were showing the differences
between with the FBI has said about her
trial,
about them looking into the email
server,
the illegal use of email server.
The fact that top secret documents were
shared cut and pasted and shared with
people that did not have the status to
be able to check those and that multiple
devices were used to access these and
then compare them to what she has
said about it.
She's just a liar.
She's a liar.
He's a liar.
You,
what do you think?
Why do you think she set that server up
in our bathroom?
What was the benefit of that do you
think?
Who the fuck knows?
What's it?
Just convenience and what she told to do
that.
It could be that.
It could be that she just didn't want
anybody to have any oversight over her
email and she wanted to have a server in
her home.
Look,
she deleted a lot of fucking emails,
thousands of emails,
and you're not supposed to do that.
Like that's a part of that Gig.
Part of that Gig is transparency.
She skirted around that kid.
I had Mike Baker in here from the CIA,
a former CIA operative who said flat out
if he had done the same thing,
he was how he says what he says,
yes,
I would be in jail now he'd be in jail.
And he was discussing how this is just
not done and everyone knows this.
This is like,
it's not a woman who just stepped into
politics for the first time.
This is someone who's been involved in
politics virtually your whole life.
I read a good article.
Somebody sent me and I'll send it to
you.
Um,
I can't remember what the magazine was
credible,
a credible magazine and the journalist,
he said,
look,
I have my point of view on Hillary and
he's not,
I left leaning,
I think he's probably more of a
conservative columnists.
And he said,
and he went and um,
he interviewed all the people that have
worked with Hillary Clinton for,
with,
and,
uh,
and even her opponents.
And it was really,
really,
really interesting to get the
perspective.
He said,
the one thing that they talk about is
number one,
she doesn't feel very comfortable in
front of,
it's not a natural fit for her to be in
front of audiences talking.
But Dude,
she's such a great speaker.
She's a great speaker.
I think her voice is very grounded and
strong like this.
It's boxy,
but they all bought it.
They didn't use words like they consider
it to be funny,
thoughtful,
and very intelligent.
Now,
uh,
that,
that was an interesting eye.
My eyes were a little bit over and I
said,
well,
the people that are close to it,
I've worked with her,
had more favorable things to say,
and I'm not a hillary supporter,
but they had more favorable than
negative,
which I thought was pretty interesting
because I'd never thought of actually
interviewing people that have worked
closely with her.
Okay.
Stop right there.
These are political people.
True.
So think about what their job is,
right?
What they do for a living and how to
make it in that world.
You have to be full of Shit and you have
to like,
yeah,
it's very much like somebody say
something bad about somebody else cause
you never know if they're going to be
it.
It's amazing.
It's the best of the best gift I've ever
read.
Well,
not only that,
he's an amazing actor.
She's amazing.
Oh my God.
Ghostbusters.
The new ghostbusters is incredible.
Those girls are so strong.
They're such strong women.
It's my new thing.
It's amazing.
My new thing is the empowerment of
women.
I love this new talk that it's just,
it's not new either.
I'm just,
she's totally empowered.
She's,
she's totally embraced her new hoodie.
Oh God.
She's bending over,
arching her back and licking her lips.
She saw power.
She's brave because she's naked and fat.
She's so brave.
All right.
If she was brave,
she'd get up at four o'clock in the
morning and hit the gym before she went
to the set.
She wouldn't
be fat anymore.
I'll tell her what's period that Melissa
McCarthy woman,
they're angry that she's losing weight
to understand this.
I love it.
They're angry that she's choosing to
become healthy.
So they're saying this is in direct
contrast to who she was before,
who we loved is this fucking cartoonish
fat lady and this cartoonish fat laid
who we want to pretend is healthy.
Yeah.
You know,
there's a fucking slew of people out
there that have blogs out there talking
about different things that are healthy
about being fat.
And I went down a rabbit hole one night
because some woman was writing shoes,
this obese woman.
And I was really sad when I was looking
at her photos.
And you know,
people like to highlight things that
people say about them on social media
and you know,
like,
you know,
all these people are harassing her for
being fat,
but she putting out a blog,
right?
When you putting yourself out there and
you putting a blog,
you're just going to a tree.
You put some honey out there,
you're gonna attract a certain amount of
bugs.
It's just no way around that.
Right?
But she was talking about different
aspects of being overweight that are
healthy.
And that is one weird phenomenon where
healthy people that catch a disease
sometimes don't do as well as fat people
that have the same disease.
In the old days they said you should
have some weight on you in case you get
a disease and you can fight it better.
That was always the case.
What does that,
how,
how could that be true?
I guess because maybe,
and I'm just,
this is bro Science,
but from what I remember reading your
fat can actually absorb or store,
uh,
more.
I,
I don't know where you have,
you have reserves when you're not eating
and stuff at you,
you know,
your body will use the fatty acids for
energy was that makes sense.
So your body gets into a state of
burning fat rather than burning food.
And many times when people are sick,
that's a huge issue.
Coming up with some form of energy.
My Italian relatives,
you know,
th the Sicilian side back in the day,
I remember if somebody was too skinny,
they look,
they,
they would say,
you know,
be careful.
You get sick,
you know,
you'll die.
Or was it totally makes sense,
but that doesn't mean it's healthy to be
fat,
but it just means it's like a,
it's a reserve policy in case you get a
fucking catastrophic disease,
but you also more likely to get that
catastrophic disease if you're fat.
Yeah.
So she's such a catch 22,
this book by Gary Taubes,
I just love called why we get fat and
what to do about it.
And he,
he traces the genealogy of the obesity
epidemic and he goes all the way back to
the 30s in New York City and he looks at
how ineffective all these obesity
clinics and even the science of obesity
has been.
It's been so difficult because a lot of
times they treated it like it was a
psychological disease.
Like you eat too much,
so you'd go to a psychiatrist,
um,
or they would put you on these very
restrictive diets,
1200 calories a day and you would lose
weight.
But at the end of the day,
you descend,
but also your body gets into this state
of panic.
Yes.
It tries to store energy.
Really quickly because it's worried that
you're in a famine state,
right?
So what he traces in,
and he looks at the native Americans
that were,
had to sort of
get,
get on government rations when their
land was taken and they all blew up like
balloons because they were given white
flour.
And the,
the thesis of the book is essentially
that when you eat simple carbohydrates
and a lot of carbohydrates,
especially things like white flour and
sugar,
your body produces a lot of insulin.
And for a whole bunch of metal metabolic
reasons,
it's insulin that causes you to retain
fat molecules and need more sugar for
energy.
And he does a really great job in the
buffet,
a book of explaining it.
Um,
but that sort of,
you know,
when,
when you look at it that way and when
you look at the fact that it's just a
question of changing what you put into
your body,
uh,
you know,
you will then eventually at this Keto
Diet,
for example,
it's a really good way to lose weight
and not have to restrict your calories.
It just is now.
I don't know if it's for everybody.
Uh,
there is a single die that's for
everybody.
I don't either.
Those bodies are differently.
Obviously people have different
allergies to foods like or allergies,
all sorts of things like that.
It's,
that's a great indication that we're
just,
there's so much biological diversity,
so many people have genetics that have
come from all sorts of different parts
of the world,
all sorts of different environments that
we evolve from.
There's no one single dime for obesity
is fairly recent only because when
people started eating that much sugar,
but you know the think that's universal,
right?
Like there's nothing wrong with eating a
certain amount of carbs and breads and
Pastas,
but it is universal that massive amounts
of sugar bad for you.
There's no,
I don't think there's any question any
more scientifically,
but one of the things,
it's hard for a very fat people,
obese people who have trouble with this,
who may have gotten caught into that
pattern as kids at or they have.
And it's very true that some people
genetically do put weight on.
They don't process carbs the way other
people do.
Like I can eat carbs all day and stay
very thin.
Some people just can't do that,
but for a long time,
very active.
I'm very active,
but for a long time what I'm saying is
that there's always been instilled as a
stigma,
which is your fat,
which means you are a of weak character
or you have a faulty character you're
about,
and that's why they take so much shit.
Whereas Gary Tab and his books had a lot
of it was just the fact that people
didn't know how the body worked and a
lot of this information came out in
Germany before the war.
There were these Austrian and German
scientists that we're really closing in
on what insulin does to make you gain
weight,
but guess what?
When the war was over,
no American scientists,
we're going to use German data,
right?
It was kind of like,
no,
we'll come up with our own data.
We use the rocket data.
We did use their rocket fucking scooped
up all their operation paperclip.
We scooped up all their fucking rocket
scientists and made them Americans.
There is a fucking thing about Wernher
von Braun being a great American and
like Wernher von Braun was a fucking
Nazi.
The guy who ran the NASA space program
was a straight up Nazi who the Simon
Wiesenthal Center said,
if he was alive today,
they would prosecute him for crimes
against humanity.
Damn,
I didn't know that.
They hung the five slowest workers every
day at his fucking
rocket factory in Berlin.
Sweet guys.
They've hung Jews.
They hung them in the front of the
fucking rocket factory to encourage the
workers to work faster.
One of the things that they,
they sit by the way,
coming directly from people who are
still alive,
who worked in that factory,
I believe with tattoos on their arm.
I believe it.
I don't think that's a,
I don't even think that's a point of
conjecture.
Brazy is it that we just scooped up all
those monsters and they can.
We all scooped out good at fucking
shooting Middle Dixon to the sky,
so let's come over here.
We also,
but we also scooped up a lot of a German
and Austrian Jewish scientists because
when they,
in fact,
Einstein I believe emigrated after a
number of,
or that thing was two scientists who
were Jewish were assassinated,
was shot on the street.
And so all of these like brilliant
Jewish,
uh,
scientists said,
let's get the fuck outta here and go to
the UK and go to the United States.
Will tragedy of Fritz Harbor,
the harbor method.
The [inaudible] method is incredible
stuff.
And the guy figured out a way to extract
nitrogen from the air and it's one of
the,
they say today that there's a,
there's a fantastic radio lab podcast on
this,
I think it's called the bad show.
I think that's what it's called because
there's a,
they did,
they did a good show in a bad show.
I think that's what it's called.
And would they just showed is that
sometimes,
and this,
we've all known this,
so sometimes people that have done
horrible,
horrible things are also amazing.
It's something that benefits a lot of
folks.
And this is one of the classic example.
Fritz harbor figured out this way to
extract nitrogen from the air and the
nitrogen in our bodies today.
They estimate that some 50 in nitrogen
with,
they use it for his fertilizer and for
the longest pneumonia.
Yeah.
For the longest time they used to have
to get like dead fish or mulch or
something like that.
Compost.
And then the fact that Bat Guano,
yeah.
Back when I was a big one literally bat
shit crazy was like because people would
have wars over a bat.
Shit,
it's nuts that I didn't know that but I
that's exactly,
yeah.
That's what it is.
It was fucking wars over bat shit like
cause that's how you grow your food is
amazing.
People would starve during the winter
because they didn't know how to get that
nitrogen into the soil.
And Fritz harbor is literally credited
with stopping mass scale starvation.
But then there's the other side,
other side.
Well they said that today the nitrogen
in our bodies,
50% of it came from the hopper method.
Degas though all the people today,
like literally he's responsible for a
massive increase in the population of
this world.
But he also was the guy that fucking
used gas in war for the first time.
Not only that,
he personally oversaw it,
he went to the front lines and we
started with,
it,
started with a p,
he was working on insecticides,
right?
Uh,
which is by the way,
is what Zyklon B,
which was used to gas,
the Jews.
He came up with Xy,
clown eggs,
psych on a had a smell it to it so that
you could know what it was and get the
fuck away from it.
Whereas B,
the Nazis
extracted the smell.
He will harbor was at ju.
So what a fucking crazy conundrum.
That guy found himself where his own
relatives died directly from an
invention that he creates.
Incredible.
And you know also if you,
if you take a sympathetic approach to a
man who was a patriot,
he was a patriot.
His country was at war.
He had benefited from this country.
He had a legacy in this country.
He had standing in this country and his
country was under direct threat.
And he said,
I think I know a way to help this war
effort so we can stop the enemy and you
know,
we should all again,
it's not what you think.
It's how you think we should all put
ourselves in his shoes.
If I had a way,
and I'm,
I think I'm right about that,
if I had a way as an American is Brian
Count to save my country from people I
thought were going to actually take it
over our kill a bunch of people,
including my family.
I'm going to gas the fuck out of them.
If I can invent a technique,
I'm going to gas them and I'm gonna come
up a way to shoot a rocket.
Adam,
that's so,
if that makes me a bad person,
call me Fritz slow.
Isn't it crazy though that this guy was
literally receiving the Nobel Prize for
the harbor method at the same time for
being wanted for crimes against humanity
for war criminal,
but the same people that want to try him
for war crimes dropped nuclear fucking
bombs on two cities in Japan.
Like what is a war crime?
Like when you're killing people,
like,
oh,
you killed people the wrong way.
Like we have rules,
can't kill her.
But like,
there's lemay who oversaw,
I believe,
the bombing,
the firebombing of Tokyo.
Uh,
and,
uh,
December before the,
the Hiroshima Nagasaki bombs,
this is the fire bombs,
which by the way,
killed more people,
did more distraught.
I mean,
everybody concentrates on the D two
events.
Hiroshima,
Nagasaki firebombing was,
oh,
I mean,
what we did to Dresden,
what we did to the allies,
really it was the British and the
Americans.
But,
um,
I mean dressing looks like the surface
of the moon.
Uh,
you know,
uh,
Kurt Vonnegut,
I think in the book a slaughterhouse
five talks about this and the vivid
detail,
but look at just youtube dresden before
and after Jimmy bring up Dresden,
Jimmy,
before Jimmy,
I said Jimmy said Jimmy,
right?
Dresden before and after the
firebombing.
But Curtis Lemay,
I think in a period of eight days in
Tokyo eight and I mean,
at 1 million people died from fire and
Curtis Lemay said business,
it wars the business of killing people.
And if I had been on the losing side,
I'd probably be tried as a war criminal,
and if you see Curtis Lemay,
he's always chewing on a cigar and he
was the commander and he was the one who
made those decisions and they said,
we're going to punish the German
workers.
They're real pictures though.
Look at what is this?
This?
I was like Dresden.
Dresden was a jewel.
It was a jewel and there's an beautiful
post,
like the surface of the fucking moon.
You'll see they have videos of it.
Then Jamie,
this all this is before and after the
allied bombing.
I don't know why.
It's just pictures.
See if you can find some photos,
some actual photo.
Beautiful Dresden Ruins after the allied
bombing.
Whoa.
But this is drawing worse in that
photograph.
Oh,
that's a photo.
Yeah.
There you go.
That's what it's a photo.
Oh my God.
It looks like,
If it,
all of it.
And then any time they talk about the
survivors who were just walking around
the city that had been standing for 700
years or something crazy and it was no
longer,
how would the neighbor have survived
this?
They didn't.
In fact,
people were falling over and look at
that.
Those are bodies.
People were falling down.
Um,
they were falling down because the
oxygen was sucked out of the air.
So you'd be,
you'd be on the street and you would,
you would just fall down because there
was no air.
Yes.
Or there'd be a bomb and the people
would open their shutters and stick
their head out and the aftershock would
take their heads off.
Whoa.
We're very lucky.
Very lucky.
We didn't live at this time.
She very left Bryce.
What a fucking strange thing.
[inaudible] was an apocalypse.
Giant scale war is like that.
And,
and Europe,
what was it a,
was it a 50 million people at the end of
World War II that were dead?
Maybe as many as 80 million.
Put that into context and that from
those ashes from these experiments like
fascism and the idea that you can
perfect human beings and perfect society
and create utopias from those
experiments came,
uh,
ash and 80 million graves.
And so,
and from that came right Kinda Sorta,
I mean,
the idea like if you just wanted to
improve upon human beings without
killing people that you thought were
inferior,
if you just wanted to create the uber
manch without making everybody else die
without you.
But you need to reeducate.
So reeducation camps that Pol Pot would
put people in.
You had to be marched to the countryside
because he was creating a,
you an agrarian utopia.
But why does it always have to,
why?
Why does any beneficial act like the
idea of creating better people?
Like we would all like a better society
with better people.
I mean if we all had a,
a world where everybody had perfect
genetics and nobody had to worry about
fat shaming,
you know,
like nobody had to worry about not being
attractive.
Nobody helped.
But that's not good.
So the problem is like the stress and
the anxiety of being a dork and the,
the,
the stress of being bullied.
And that's where diamonds come from.
Not good to someone.
It's not good to take advantage of
someone.
It's not good to make someone's life
hell.
But a lot of times that's where you get
a Marvin Gaye.
Of course,
you know,
you get these,
these jewels of art.
Yeah.
You know,
you get these people that come out of
these horrible environments and they
have this power to them,
but you have to create,
you have,
you're right.
You still have to create some respite.
You know,
that the great,
the greatest,
the Great Matthew Arnold who said that
the United States is the land of the
stock market and big guns and,
and powerful,
you know,
an agrarian state,
it can feed the land of Prince.
What he also said,
I was going to say,
he said,
we have to always remember to create
safe haven for our gentler spirits are
Weirdos and people that think
differently and active.
And we,
that's what you get prints,
little Richard,
Marilyn Manson and all the things that
make our culture interesting.
Yeah.
And that's a very important thing to
keep in mind when you,
when you,
um,
but again,
look,
when you talk about,
um,
bombing and how we're getting better,
think about for a second the methodology
in our brain of how we,
a lot of people think of not only
terrorism,
and I'm guilty of this too,
or even say something like cancer.
So if you have cancer,
there's one method of treating it and
sometimes it works,
which is there's a tumor,
let's cut it out.
Let's cut the tumor out was another
method of treating and which was diet
and health and taking care of your body
before it ever happens.
This is one of the things that you're
talking now about the duality is what
I'm saying is that we,
we fall sometimes into the mindset that
every problem can be cut out and,
and removed,
right.
Instead of saying prevention,
what you just said,
what you just said is there's another,
there might be another tact in,
in every issue.
So when you,
when we talk about,
um,
the bad guys and we talk about,
we have to in,
and listen,
there's,
there's a place in the time to take out
the bad guys.
There's no question of course,
but,
you know,
but we have to be careful that we have,
we don't fall into one way of thinking
and one way of dealing with what we
consider threats.
Right,
right.
Because we could make the problem worse.
Um,
and instead,
sometimes we might want to say,
maybe this time,
maybe this is a problem that doesn't
require cutting and radiation and,
uh,
you know,
removing,
maybe it's what you just said.
Maybe we should approach it systemically
from a different angle that's not as,
uh,
not as violent and not as physical.
Yeah.
Well,
there's also the problem of the
charismatic leader and there's also a
problem of people wanting to be a part
of a team.
Like you were talking about,
if you could guess the people that are a
threat to the United States,
but who are those people?
Cause they're just people.
The idea that somehow or another,
someone who lives in Italy who,
uh,
I've never met is against me.
Uh,
someone who lives in the United States
who they've never met.
That's preposterous.
We just don't know each other.
And when you get,
by the way,
when I was in Italy,
one of the weirdest fucking things about
it,
and I've never been there before,
so I don't know that,
but the people that were there were
describing to me how everything has
changed.
I was talking to this one cab driver,
it was really interesting guy.
And,
uh,
he was,
we were commenting on,
was asking him about everywhere you
look,
they have these land rover defenders
that are in Cammo with these military
people standing out there with fucking
machine guns everywhere,
everywhere.
And I said,
is this normal?
And he said,
no.
He said,
this is the new way.
He's like,
is a,
the world
is changing.
He said,
this is not a good world.
this is not good.
And I said,
so this is a direct response to the
terrorist threats and the things that
have been happening in Paris.
He goes,
yes,
yes.
He goes,
they don't want it to happen here.
So,
so all the places where there was
tourists,
where was the Vatican?
Whether it was the coliseum.
You saw these,
these camouflage land rover defenders in
these public displays,
guy's gun and a woman.
I saw a woman,
I was thinking about punching her and
taking her gun.
It's like,
I think it can sound as women are no
joke know.
I don't think so.
I got it.
They're trained to react.
My Guy,
that's my guy,
that's my gun.
It wasn't obviously,
I'm kidding,
but it is.
It is weird to see these people.
They're standing out there holding guns
and they had fucking very serious looks
on their face and they're scanning the
crowd looking left and looking right in.
A lot of Middle Eastern people there.
A lot of fucking people dressed up like
beekeepers.
A lot of poor ladies with gloves on and
Ninja masks and I was like,
what in the fuck,
2016 and you've got people wandering the
streets of one of the greatest cities in
the world and our liberal democracy.
I'm fucking that.
That talks about giving people their on
the serenity on him,
but they were,
yeah,
and all the women like Italian women
trust like,
Oh yeah,
I was looking for Dick.
Oh well they're just very,
I consider they trust their minimalists.
Excuse me sir.
They're mental mess and they did.
They know how to,
I'm fan.
I'm a fan of hallways.
Did you see what happened in France over
the weekend?
It's um,
this man stabbed a woman and her three
children at a,
at a resort for being scantily dressed.
This Muslim man.
Oh,
what in the fuck man.
Just,
well,
it's such a bankrupt.
It's such a bankrupt philosophy,
if you can even call it that.
This ideology is an ideology.
I'm going to kill you.
I thought you talk about people who are
caught in a trap.
These,
this isis ideology talk about being
caught in a past.
This guy,
this guy wasn't nicest.
He wasn't an isis guy.
He was just some radical Muslim.
Some someone who deeply believes what
he's been taught,
his ideology so powerful that he's
willing to stab an eight year old kid in
the lungs is poor fucking kid.
At a collapse.
A little girl,
a little girl,
cause she was wearing a beach house.
Jesus Christ.
Well this is a guy.
Um,
it sounds like you've might've been
mentally ill or the guy drove all those
people and needs that happened while I
was there is,
I didn't say it nice.
Nice.
That happened while I was there.
It was a,
well this is the other thing is again,
not only do they do that because they're
fanatical,
they think they're actually going to
change something and make the world a
better place by,
by behaving in this mad fashion.
In some ways they might because they're
going to unleash the Jocko willink on
the world who are going to go out there
and they're going to fucking kill people
like this.
They're there.
They're going to fucking get people to
the point where they lose all tolerance.
Well,
I'm Kinda shit point and I'm pretty
tolerant and I'm getting to that point.
And here's the,
here's the thing about when you think
about isis.
So I was talking to my buddy who's a CIA
guy,
you know,
he's at,
he's at Delta Guy.
He's one of these were bill kind of a
guys
who's in there and does all the dirty
work.
And he said,
um,
I said,
you know,
let's,
why don't we just bomb,
uh,
the,
their strongholds,
you make a martyr.
Well,
no,
he also said,
he said,
you have to understand that that's not
like they're all camped out in one area.
They're in a town the size of,
you know,
let's say Baltimore and there they have
safe houses,
but for the most part,
they're all over that place.
But more importantly,
as Isis fighters die,
what they do is they come to families
that are peace loving families and they
say,
listen,
we need to,
we need to conscript your son and your
two other sons.
Right?
They're there.
They now belong to isis.
Now you can say no and die or you can
bring,
bring them over for the cause because
you better be down cause that what's
going on.
That's what's going on now.
Where's this happening?
We'll pull in the world in Syria,
in Iraq,
in,
in those places where they have
strongholds.
[inaudible] people are joining
voluntarily.
Yes,
yes.
They,
including European women.
Have you seen this crazy shit where
girls are going from England and they're
joining isis?
Yeah.
They're also getting their also getting
wholesale just destroyed.
Oh Man,
I just fucking dying.
And now isis is trying to support the
families of the martyrs and they're
running out of money and you know,
so they're losing the,
they're losing the physical battle.
But the ideology is always going to
inspire fuck faces.
Like this guy who kills children.
And I think in that case,
you know,
you do need a strong presence and people
willing to shoot those people before
they do what they do.
It's really hard to prevent though.
Well,
it's hard to prevent crazy people.
Yeah.
And the word crazy is not the right
word.
It's hard to prevent even addicts,
psychopaths,
it's hard to prevent people.
Like,
I mean,
forget religious ideology.
The guy who fucking shot up those people
in the movie theater in Colorado.
It's hard to prevent that.
Yeah.
It's,
it's hard to,
I mean that,
that happened more than once.
Right?
I mean,
how many times people didn't,
someone gets shot up in Amy Schumer's
movie.
The one where there are people that went
to see train wreck that was right,
right.
Yeah.
And because she was a,
what would you set up?
What do you think is the answer?
I mean it's a good question.
The answer is the answer.
This is a little bit radical,
but is the answer.
Let all of us carry a gun.
How are you gonna stop that truck with a
gun?
I don't know.
The trucks are more dangerous than guns,
you know,
it's fucked up.
I kind of predicted that that truck
attack during the Steven crowder
podcasts and I didn't even realize I did
it.
Somebody posted on the integrator in the
Internet,
like a clip of it.
Like what's to stop someone?
Cause we were talking about gun control
and I'm like,
the problem is mentally insane.
People that are willing to kill people
and they could do it a lot of ways,
man.
And I was like,
what's to stop someone from taking a car
and driving through a fucking crowd of
people.
There's not much you can do
about it,
but you can't shoot him in the face so
that they die in the car.
Maybe I do get lucky
hit them.
You know how hard it is to shoot at
someone when they're driving at you in a
car.
It's hard to shoot a deer that's
standing still and in you resting your
gun on a rock.
But it's possible.
It's possible.
I'd rather have that answer then have to
run and scream with my kids.
I'd rather be able to stand my ground
and fucking squeeze off,
you know?
Right.
Six rounds in his direction.
And I really mean that.
You'd know it's,
it's,
there's an argument there and I think
the argument against that,
that,
you know,
you should not have that because you're
more likely to kill someone in your
family.
And you know,
that's not a great argument either.
I think on both sides,
like the real issue is mental health.
The real issue is inequality.
The real issue is people growing up.
And,
and when I say inequality,
I don't necessarily even mean rights.
I mean in the environment in which your
soul enters this world.
Like what,
what,
what is the environment that you and I
entered?
Well,
we have really nice parents and we got
really lucky.
We got born in America and we didn't,
we even born American,
born in the Philippines,
there's Jesus Christ.
I was 14 years old,
barely 100 different countries too.
I get my edge.
But you,
you,
you got lucky.
You have a really nice family.
You know,
I got lucky,
great family,
like Nice people.
You know,
that's very fortunate.
If you were born in Iraq or in Saudi
Arabia or in Afghanistan or in any of
these places where they're dealing with
these ancient ideologies,
you're fucked.
It's like,
it's like there's a race and the race is
30 miles long and you're starting out at
mile one where some people are at mile
29 like there's no way.
It's no way this is fair.
It's no way.
It's just not fair.
And there's gotta be a way through
either time or effort or just the sheer
expression of ideas that permeate
through this world where it slowly,
yeah,
slowly but surely things have to even
out to the point where people realize
the correct way to behave and treat
people.
Look,
you could say religious tolerance all
you want,
but when there's a fucking woman dress
like a Ninja at the mall,
that lady is not in a good place.
She,
she's being forced to dress like that.
This is not her idea.
There's no way it is.
This is an idea that was stuck into her
life when she was a small person and she
grew up with that idea and now she's
married to some guy who enforces that
idea and this guy's walking around with
a fucking golf shirt on and his wife's
dress like a Ninja.
I mean,
it says,
man,
I think that it makes their country
weaker if you get,
yeah,
you guys arise and,
and,
and you know,
creates these sort of fencing around an
entire class of people and agenda.
If you take women and say,
you guys have to walk a little bit
behind me.
You have,
we just know that that doesn't work.
You're wasting a lot of human potential.
Yes.
A lot of people with ideas that can make
the world a better place.
And you also,
you're,
you're stifling the debate and the
discussion.
Look,
there's a lot of people that think
different than me,
man.
A lot of people,
whether they're from different parts of
the world or whether they have different
likes or dislikes and they have
different,
uh,
art that they appreciate.
And I,
I like hearing their point of view.
There's a lot of people that I don't
agree with what they're saying and I
like to hear what they say.
There's radical feminists that I
listened to their ideology and
unlistened to what they're saying.
And I try to figure out where the fuck
they're coming from.
I try to figure,
okay,
is this a direct response to something
they've experienced in their life?
Like how much of this has to deal with
them being persecuted?
How much of them it has to,
how much of what people say has to do
with their direct experiences with the
opposite sex.
Like when you look at a bunch of
feminists,
right?
And some of them have pink hair and they
weigh 300 pounds and you,
you know,
life was not fucking awesome for them
around men.
You just know it wasn't he?
Well,
how much of this anti male sort of
ideology that they're espousing,
like how much of that comes from their
direct experiences with men and how
different would it be if they grew up
looking like Julia Roberts?
Right.
I mean,
a lot.
Really good.
Um,
one of the things I do with my podcast,
the Brian Council now is I do,
wait a minute,
wait a minute.
You have a podcast?
I have a,
I have,
I have the fight in the Cayman.
Wait,
wait a minute,
Wayne.
Man,
you brought back the Brian Cowen.
Shall I ha I do it once a week and I
talk about a book about this.
I sent you,
I sent you one of them just for you to
listen to because I did it with this
guy,
Hunter Mountain.
I don't listen.
He was brilliant.
Just tell you right now.
I sent it to here like whatever.
But it was a super busy,
we had an amazing,
I'm very,
very busy,
but I had an amazing conversation with
my buddy hunter that amazing.
Like you can't believe it happened.
Is it more?
It was good.
My buddy hunter is really good at
reading everything and putting it in the
context where I can understand it.
You know what I mean?
Like he,
he can put it,
he can create useful,
he can turn it into a useful,
you know what I mean?
But you can read a bunch of books but
you don't have to put it together.
This motherfucker can put it all
together and contextualizes it and
everything else.
And we read this book,
we'll read a book and then talk about
it.
So we read this book called the secret
of their success at the secret of our
success by Joseph Henrik.
And the book is,
the theme of the book is basically this
and it's to your point,
human beings are smart because they
borrow culture.
Human beings are smart because they have
societies that excel have to be open and
have to be open enough so that they can
borrow the best things from other
cultures.
So for example,
if you and I are put in the middle of
the Arctic would get a flat unless we
find a bunch of Innuendo.
We're dead in about three days.
You know,
if you and I are in the Amazon,
if you take an intuit who can kick ass
and find seal meat and everything else
and put them in the Amazon,
he's fun.
He doesn't know,
he doesn't have the culture.
Human beings survive and grow and excel
because we are really good at learning
from each other,
borrowing ideas.
It's called the diffusion of innovation.
We are,
that's the most important thing.
And when you have societies that have
these strong rules and the strong
ideologies that keep people essentially
restricted,
you are not to have
the free flow exchange of ideas.
Look at,
for example,
mixed martial arts.
Think about where martial arts has come
once the ultimate fighting championship
and the grace he's created this crazy
thing where everybody got to fight
everybody else.
Pretty soon everybody starts sharing
secrets.
Everybody starts to Kinda like go,
this works,
this doesn't work.
And you were putting it in an arena
where you were actually,
it was just a very open place.
It was the people who have been ground.
It was a proven ground and you could
borrow ideas and people are,
look at what they're doing now,
their borrower coaches here,
I have this idea in submissions and
kickboxing and all this.
That's how societies,
that's how innovation happens.
That's the best way to get ideas to move
forward.
And again,
the problem with Wa this sort of
countries that are restrictive like
Russia,
like Saudi Arabia with the strong sort
of either cultures of power or cultures
of religion is that they create um,
a very,
very,
it's a very difficult atmosphere.
Not only,
not only to be open with your ideas but,
but to benefit from your ideas.
You are not going to start a company
like apple in Russia when you know that
the government like Putin or whoever is
co could take it anytime they want.
Where would be the incentive that I'm
going to work for 20 years.
He's buddies with Putin.
Exactly.
Might be able to pull it off,
but you'll never do it in Saudi Arabia.
Now it's an economy of influence,
not a meritocracy.
Let me ask you this,
cause this is a kind of an interesting
thought that's going through my head.
Do you think that one of the things
that's going on today that just really
wasn't going on,
I mean in the 70s you had the Iran
hostage crisis with Jimmy Carter and all
that jazz,
but if you really go back and think
about what that was all about and if you
really look at the history of the United
States intervention in the Middle East,
it was really about controlling
resources,
controlling now also controlling Soviet
influence.
Yeah,
controlling Soviet influence,
but that was also about resources too
because they were trying to,
the mujahideen,
they were trying to control Afghanistan
and they had wanted to get the natural
gas pipelines and there's,
there's a lot of it to that deals with
monopolizing natural resources and the
amount of money that you can get from
there.
And then also the amount of natural
resources that could be used to
strengthen military,
you know,
a regimes there.
There's,
there's a lot of control issues in that,
but you didn't have the kind of
terrorist activity that you're having
today,
which also coincides with the freedom
and expression of ideas and information
at an unprecedented rate that we're all
experiencing today.
And the areas where this is not true.
The areas where the freedom of
expression and the tolerance of ideas,
I mean if you look at the United States,
there's some some nonsense that's going
on today with political correctness and
there's some complete the the the the
left that's taken so far left that it
almost becomes right because they're
just completely trolling but could not
just controlling but so,
so infatuated with the idea of enforcing
their version of what equality is,
equality is and what life is on
everybody else.
That it becomes this like,
oh this is radical.
You've very tyrannical.
But point is this is this is the,
the west,
I mean this is where we are.
We are in the real marketplace of ideas.
This is the boiling point of all these
ideas where things are changing at this
radical rate and this is the world that
is also being attacked and really being
opposed by this completely constricted
world that really doesn't feel like it
has a chance.
Like this world is trying desperately to
cling to these old ways.
D I mean if you look at,
look what Isis is,
they are desperately trying to cling to
these ancient religious ideologies that
were established in,
in a way that does not allow for the
even exchange of ideas and information
and this,
this new way of,
but this is also this new way,
is also attached of course,
to the military industrial complex.
It's also attached to that the idea that
there's hundreds of different,
some different military bases and
hundreds of different countries where
we're in control of massive,
the mountains has been,
has been noted.
It hasn't been,
you know,
terrorism by the way of the 70s I
remember being in Rome airport,
they had plenty of guys with machine
guns because of their red book Grit
Brigade.
There was timing as terrorism.
There was Palestinian terrorists and
back then when they killed the people,
the Olympics,
Munich,
yeah,
there was always terrorist,
but a much smaller scale than today.
Much smaller.
I don't know about that.
I don't know if that's true because
terrorism was a terrorism.
There was never anything like isis
before.
No,
there wasn't there.
This is a new thing and I,
I,
but this really powerful,
but I have to stop you there because,
because when you say there wasn't
anything,
like I said,
you're right.
But for example,
in Indonesia,
which was essentially an American ally,
uh,
in Indonesia,
had I just lost my yet,
take a look at how many people in one
year died during the communist purge and
I think it was 1965 by many,
many accounts.
The,
uh,
there were probably 1 million people,
most of whom were sort of take the
commando oxy,
they were the sort of civilian
conscripts that the military kind of
recruited and said,
find us the communists in your villages.
And they were marched down to the river.
They had their heads chopped off and by
many accounts,
almost a million quote unquote
communists in a period of about a year
in Indonesia were slaughtered.
Let's take a look.
These are all related,
but no one's saying that.
That that my point is,
is
what I'm trying to get at is I wonder if
what is going on now is almost the same
thing that's going on with like a two
party system.
It's an US versus them thing,
but it's combined with the os which is
this what's going on in the western
world.
I mean obviously the Western world has
plenty of problems,
but one thing the western world has
pretty clearly is the even exchange of
information and ideas.
You might not agree with these ideas and
you might mean and then that's it.
There's a problem with that as well,
but,
but you have access to them,
you have access to them and this access
is like,
well that's one of the things that's
going on with twitter and I dunno if you
know about this,
but Milo Yiannopoulos,
you know what he is?
Yeah.
He got banned from twitter for writing a
bad review about ghostbusters,
which essentially confirms what he said
about the regressive left is that
they're trying to stifle ideas like w
and then they're saying that he's
responsible for the harassment of Leslie
Jones.
Right.
Which is horrible.
You know what people did.
She's a fucking comedian.
She's awesome.
Great.
She's not great.
She's funny shit,
man.
Um,
but also this is just trolls,
right?
You're always going to have trolls.
But he didn't do that.
He didn't,
he's not responsible for,
he didn't like sending them who wasn't
the catalyst to the,
yeah.
But what he did was make an incredible
amount of sense when he was describing
that you cannot make fun of this movie.
You cannot criticize this movie if you
do,
you're labeled a massage.
Dennis and he talked about how
preposterous this movie is that these
women are all kicking ass and every man,
the movie a buffoon and the women don't
have any negative traits or qualities at
all.
They're there.
They're super powerful and super awesome
and hilarious.
And the humor is nonexistent because
they put them in this restrictive box.
He got banned from twitter for that
band,
for twitter,
for this you,
you what?
They've,
they're blaming him on the harassment
that Leslie experience inside of the
inside anything.
He made a provocative article about a
piece of art and that's what that movie
is a piece of art.
So they are,
they are guilty of censorship in the,
in the worst way.
Well,
what they're doing is they're stifling
ideas they don't agree with and they've,
they've decided that the twitter
established some weird fucking thing
called the trust and Security Council or
something like that.
And they brought all these social dress
justice words.
Jamie looked at up,
what the fuck is that called?
That they tried to do,
but they brought on all these people for
this.
I was like mouth China.
But Chase is Christ very,
very bizarre.
It is thought,
well look,
I'm against harassment.
If you could stop people from being
shitty to people and you say,
well,
here's someone who's using twitter and
they're going after people in a very
shitty way.
But the problem with that is look at how
many fucking people have made shitty,
horrible,
evil comments about police officers.
All police officers,
trust and safety council.
When it comes to safety,
everyone plays a role.
Please make that larger so I can read
it.
Powers.
Twitter empowers every voice to shape
the world,
but you can't do that unless you feel
safe and confident enough to express
yourself freely and with the world
around you to help give your voice more
power.
Twitter does not tolerate behavior
intended to harass,
intimidate,
or use fear to silence another user's
voice.
Very general,
by the way,
listening in general then,
so now you have a council that is
deciding whether or not your good enough
for twitter as well.
You know what the first thing they did
with him?
They couldn't figure out what to do with
him.
They took away his verification.
Wow.
What?
What does that have to do with,
wow,
what does that,
he's not verified anymore.
They took away a little blue chat.
Yeah,
it's very dangerous.
It's a very dangerous,
slippery slope.
But we see the scenario.
Universities,
you do exactly the same thing.
When they did that,
he gained 20,000 new followers
immediately because there was a massive
backlash.
Yeah.
So now they're in a place where there is
even more backlash because if you look
at the actual words that he typed versus
what they're accusing him of,
and it just doesn't stack up,
it's clear that they don't like him
because he's a Republican.
He's a trump supporter.
He and he is a fucking troll.
I love him.
I think he's hilarious.
He's a troll.
But in the marketplace of ideas,
you should be able to combat his
trolling behavior.
The thing I gag without gagging,
without gagging and engage him,
engage him in a debate and a vigorous
spirit.
Exactly.
Gag The guy.
Right.
If you really feel like he has done
something egregious,
if he's done something that can be
criticized,
criticized it.
That's right.
And if he's actually harassing people,
if he's actually saying,
Hey,
go find Leslie Jones and,
and throw dog shit at,
or do something horrible to her or slash
or tires or something like that,
he's actually doing something like that.
Yeah.
Then you know that he's doing,
that's where the,
that you don't get up in a crowded movie
theater and scream fire because you'll
create a stampede.
Yeah,
right.
Exactly.
You know my Angela talked about that
when she said where the Ku Ku Klux Klan
was saying we have a freedom of speech
and my Angela said you're a freedom
ends.
Your freedom of speech can end when
you're literally telling people to hang
me and you're telling a mob and I'm
standing right there that,
that the inciting them.
That's,
that's probably where you know we should
take a look at things.
I mean,
and we all know,
we all know the line.
What we don't know about what,
no,
I'm saying,
I'm saying that that there is something
called common decency and you know
people like to jump to these extremes
but it's not,
it doesn't inform the debate.
I think what you're saying is so
important and then the idea that you've
got to create a safe haven for those
that you agree with and disagree with.
Disagree with Milo all the time.
I mean,
he and I are friends and I've had him on
the podcast twice.
And when we talk,
I'm mock them when we have fun.
I mean,
but he's a good guy,
but he's just really right wing.
I also think his trolling is so fucking
sophisticated and he's one of the ones
that was saying that he believes that
Melania,
how do you say her name?
Trust.
Why trump?
Melania?
Is that her name?
Yeah.
He thinks that they did it on purpose.
He thinks trump is a master troll and he
thinks that the plagiarism was on
purpose because now more people are
talking about it and then more people
are,
I don't know if that's true,
but I think it's hilarious that you did,
you know that his tweet,
trump's tweet that he put out to
congratulate his wife for speaking is
exactly verbatim the same tweet that
Obama put out to congratulate his wife
or speaking.
Interesting.
Exactly.
Wow.
Every single word in the exact same
order.
Wow.
Yes.
Uh,
that's,
that's pretty calculated.
I don't know.
I don't think he writes his own tweets.
That apparently wasn't true.
Is it fake photoshopped?
Oh,
this motherfucker,
they got me.
So that was the thing they did.
I'm sorry about that folks.
That's another thing that they did with
the Leslie Jones,
which she was really upset is that
trolls were taking words,
um,
and putting them like they were taking a
photoshop and making her like her name,
like what she had,
you know,
heard her twitter name and then writing
horrible shit about gay people and then
putting it in there.
Jesus.
But Leslie Jones and again,
I love her.
I think she's really funny.
She said some kind of fucked up things
on,
on twitter herself and you know,
things that can be construed as racist.
One of the things she said about white
people being shit,
fuck white people,
Shit.
Like something like that.
It was a on on Breitbart.
See if you could,
you'd find the actual,
uh,
things that they were,
there were saying that like,
how could Leslie Jones get away with
saying this?
But Milo gets banned for writing an
article and I'm not you ma'am.
But I think what Leslie said,
like white people,
Shit,
it could've been that she was saying
like,
someone did something and Goddamn white
people,
this is some white people,
Shit.
You know,
like she's funny.
Like when people climb into a zoo and
try to fucking hug a tiger,
that's why people,
that's why people shit.
That's funny though.
And let's say anybody who knows let's,
no,
she's great.
She's just that fucking Dall Lord have
mercy white people.
Shit.
What does that mean though?
It's white people shit.
Like they do,
I mean,
what does that mean?
Like why did she say that?
Like what is that about?
Who imagine a white person,
but look at this,
imagine a white person saying that about
black people.
I understand,
but I think I,
you know,
we've heard this before,
we,
it's fine.
Leslie Jones is not a racist and Leslie
Jones's,
it never been anything but really kind
to people around her.
Okay.
But hold on a second because sometimes
people say things that are racist and
they're not racist.
They're just trying to be fun.
Yes.
Like,
you know,
I mean how many 2 cents and if sometimes
the Jeff Ross is hilarious and he says a
lot of racial stuff when he exerts
Silberman.
Sarah Silverman.
But Jeff Ross in particular because he's
really good at roasting people and a lot
of the stuff that he says like,
you know,
he crosses what some people would say is
align but what is he doing?
He's being funny.
There is,
there is a difference.
So a lot of times if you're Hispanic,
um,
if you're,
you know,
you're from
a marginalized group,
you can get away with it because you all
share in a common experience of
repression,
right?
So like gay people can mock straight
people guide,
go ahead.
Mock me for like composer,
who cares?
That's what I mean.
Cause we don't,
we've never had to pay a price for that
kind of oppression.
We haven't,
not physically and not,
not economically because we've been
oppressed for being straight forever.
It's a constant thing.
People were just so mad that we're not
saying read or fucking breeder out there
making babies.
Exactly what's fucking auto.
And George had a great line,
you know,
auto and George,
if you don't know,
Otto was this fucking great,
hilarious comedian who had a puppet
named George and his Papa was evil and
these bushy eyebrows and the puppet
would say these fucked up things and
auto would go,
ah,
I can't believe you're saying that.
Like what the Hell Creek?
And the puppet would say,
he goes,
Hey,
I don't understand where all these
fucking queer as it coming from for a
group of people that can't breed,
where the fuck are they all coming from?
It's like you had these like who'd say
like purposely ignorant shit as his
puppet.
Yeah.
Well you know,
a lot of times all of us think
outrageous thoughts.
We think prejudice thoughts.
It's part of being a human being man is
a friend of mine who was dealing with
um,
these folks that are Jewish that are
incredibly cheap.
And this friend of mine was saying like,
how fucking embarrassing is it when
someone just reenact the most disgusting
stereotype about a race,
like a Chinese guy,
he just closes his eyes and just drive
straight into traffic.
Like this is fucking horrible
stereotypes that like when you see them,
like,
oh,
come on man.
If I was Chinese and I saw someone
driving like that,
I'd be like,
you motherfucker.
You know what I'm dealing with here?
Just being shy.
If there's an accident and I'm involved,
people go,
oh,
of course the black and Asian guy go car
accident.
Well,
do you know,
do you know what Dunbar's principle is?
Yes.
Yeah,
and that's,
we have a limited number of people we
can keep within our heads.
Right?
Right.
But that also plays a part and
stereotyping.
There's a limited amount of information
that we can kind of like keeping our
heads right.
So actually stereotyping was something
that kept us safe.
You're talking about when you talk about
stereotyping,
what you're really talking about is
pattern recognition and chunking
information,
right?
You're looking at something because you
don't have a lot of time.
You're looking at a dude.
It's like Dove,
David [inaudible] joke about,
you know,
he said he was sitting there and he and
this guy walked up to him,
he's already done this joke so I'm not
selling,
I'm not,
I'm not ruining it.
But he said,
you know,
look,
we assume things all the time.
You know,
he goes,
I saw this guy with teardrop tattoos,
he had a knife and I was like,
I don't want to stay.
I don't want us to hang around here.
And the girl goes,
don't assume it could be a chef.
I'm like that's fine.
He could be a chef.
But if you'll pull your pants down and
you've got a bunch of blisters and your
genitals,
I'm not going to assume you got stung by
a pack of bees.
You know,
at the end of the day you do
stereotyped,
you make choices based on how you,
you know,
what the information you get and you do
it very quickly because sometimes that
information and keep you safe.
A cop.
A lot of times when they see they can
tell if somebody shouldn't be somewhere
cause they'll look for certain things
out of state plates,
fast food wrappers,
that person's drive and they're on their
way somewhere.
There are lots of different little
signals that cause you to profile,
right?
Cause sometimes profiling is what's
called good police work.
Uh,
we all do it.
We all,
we all,
when I'm driving and I see a dude in his
car and I see the back of his head,
I can make a lot of fucking assumptions
on how he's driving and whether or not
he's going to signal like an old dude
with a hat do it all the time.
I do it all the time and I got to speak
by this guy.
I got a beep my horn before I go by
cause he might just swerving cause he's
a fucking dummy.
You know what I'm saying?
So some of this is just being a human
being.
And again,
it's how our minds work and we probably
all share very similar thought patterns
with even our enemies or even the people
we don't like.
Right.
But being like,
being a Jewish person,
it's really cheap.
Like super cheap.
But that comes from that's different.
No,
because that's characteristic.
The way I would look at it as this.
So I'd say you'd say a Jew,
that Jewish person,
that's cheap.
Right.
And I would say what I would look at is
I'd say,
well,
hold on for a second.
If you've been a Jew,
you have a history and we can go back
3,500 years,
but let's just go back.
Uh,
I dunno,
let's go back 2000 years.
You got a history of a lot of people in
their twenties.
Nope.
It doesn't matter.
Listen,
do you got a lot of people blaming the
Jews for killing Christ?
Right?
And so usually if you look at history,
especially European history,
they were either kicked out or they were
killed.
So what happens is if you don't have a
homeland,
you don't have a homeland and you're a
Jew.
All right?
Don't they have a homeland?
No luck yet.
But that's very recent.
What does that 1948 yeah.
So,
so as a Jew,
when you actually don't have,
you know,
a country,
I'm just,
you know,
as an example,
guess what your security is.
Your fucking security at the end of the
day is how thick your wallet is.
Because money,
money is how you survived.
You know the reason that a lot of Jews,
the reason Jews were into the jewelry
trade diamonds,
little diamonds or something you could
pick up,
put an a pouch and run the fuck away
really quickly.
You could transport your wealth.
So they were like,
well,
we're kept out of banking.
We kept that,
all of these things,
but we can make clothing and we can,
and we're jewelers and they came to this
country.
Those immigrants came to this country
with those two skills,
Irish came to this country with,
hey,
I got two hands.
I can work a farm.
What do you need me to do?
The Jews were like,
I,
uh,
I can make fucking really nice clothes
and I can label them and I can get you
to think that they're even nicer.
Because I understand a little bit about
marketing.
Oh.
And by the way,
I got diamonds,
they there,
there were,
there were certain things that they were
forced into and they came to this
country and they had a skill set.
So I look at that and I go,
Ooh,
that's just cultural residue.
That's just cultural residential
culture.
You were taught that that's how you get
ahead
and you were taught that keeping hold on
your money is by the way also a way to
ensure your survival.
So the more you learn about,
you know,
the more you learn about people's
history and the more you learn about our
biology,
the more we learn about brain science.
I think the more compassionate and makes
us,
well that's also why a lot of people
feel that some Asian folks are bad
drivers cause they used to mind their
own business not looking left and right.
And when they walk they walk straight
ahead and they bumped into each other
all the time.
That's great.
That's fucking great.
That's what we will do.
A friend of mine is China was explaining
this to me.
He's like,
if you go to China and you walked down
the street,
he goes,
people just bounce off each other like
cars.
And he goes,
and it's not offensive.
It's just what they're doing.
They're not doing it on purpose.
It's just like when you're dealing with
billions of people,
like this is how you do it.
Yeah.
You just,
you to just got to plow forward.
If you ever seen intersections in China,
yes,
you've seen videos of intersections is
fucking terrified.
It's insanity.
It's fucking terrifying chaos.
It's the aunts.
It's like it was terrifying.
It allows the,
they drive like fucking savages in
Italy.
Yeah.
I mean there's this roundabouts,
well walking,
we're driving into the roundabout what
it called Jesus and the driver just like
skillfully maneuvers around this,
but like,
look at this,
look at this fucking mad bays.
But they figure it out.
Work they left,
they write,
they zoom around each other.
They're driving slowly and they're all
making their own.
So at 25 miles an hour,
they say anything below 25 miles an
hour.
Human beings are very good at
navigating.
You know,
that's a good example.
And this is kind of a weird overhead
view,
but this is,
this is actually manageable,
but I've seen some shit that just does
look manageable.
You also see people die in those
intersections.
Yeah.
Well how about the people that are
walking,
they just walk across the street and
pray that people avoid them?
Like,
Oh,
you get,
God dammit.
Yeah.
I mean there's a lot of cultures that
have their own little thing that they do
to sort of deal with the numbers that
they're dealing with.
And you know,
you see that in America to one of the
things that I really like about small
towns when I go to a small,
like I was in Bozeman,
Montana recently,
there's only 35,000 residents,
Bozeman,
Montana.
It's a great town and everybody drives a
really nice,
everybody's like fucking super chill.
Yeah.
There's not that many people.
People like real easy going,
let everybody.
And I realized like,
what will your dealing with in Los
Angeles,
like I felt at the moment I got off the
plane when I went from Montana to here.
The moment you get here,
you're like,
hey gotta go gotta go cut this guy off.
Get ahead.
Get ahead of like there's a feeling in
the air.
And they did a study and one of the
things that they did this study on was
they put up cameras in cities and they
measured the amount of footsteps that
people take.
Like how quickly they walk.
And then they measured how,
how many syllables people say in a
minute,
how quickly they talk.
And through those two numbers,
they were able to accurately estimate
how many people lived in that city down
to like a thousand.
God,
I love that stuff.
Yeah,
like
a shit load of people.
People walk faster and they talk fast.
If you have less people,
they slow down.
Well,
Gail Collins,
who is a connoisseur New York Times says
that right wing and left wing people is,
she goes,
it's all about space.
When you're,
uh,
when you're,
you become more of a socialist when you
have to contend with all your neighbors.
So you live in a building and,
and you,
it requires cooperation.
It requires waiting in line.
It requires all these things.
When you live in Bozeman,
Montana and you have all that space,
you can preach self reliance,
you can sort of talk about the value of,
you know,
serenity,
personal serenity,
self reliance and all that stuff.
So it does play a real factor in your
psychology.
It's like,
yeah,
no,
go ahead.
No,
I was going to say Malcolm Gladwell in
his book,
he said,
uh,
blend,
I think it was blink where you
mentioned,
um,
when people would come to his office and
if you mentioned Florida raisins and
orange juice,
people left the room a lot slower.
Do you know why?
Why?
Because they thought of old people and
retirement.
Whoa.
And so it played a factor in their gate.
They left,
they left the fucking all lesson spy
walked down the aisle where they walked
down the hallway more measured because
they,
you put the idea of an old person in
their brain.
Well,
that's what I was going to say is this
is where the role of colleges are very
interesting because college is sort of
throw a monkey wrench into that because
college is take a small town and turn it
very liberal,
which ordinarily would not be that way.
You're dealing with small rural
environments.
You usually deal with conservative
populations that are Christian and you
know they're in the fucking,
you know,
Republicans sort of ideas.
There's also something else about
liberal towns.
They're little small liberal towns like
you're talking about.
I don't think they turn them liberal.
What they really do is they take away
any existential threat.
For the most part,
they make those towns super safe.
There are a lot of rules that would
penalize anybody,
for example,
young men for misbehaving by punching
each other in the face or imposing their
aggression on a weaker group of people.
I think that's also what,
how I characterize a liberal,
small academic town.
They are safe for the most part,
safe environments for you to figure the
world out and express yourself.
Do you,
do you know what I'm saying?
But yeah,
safe or like boulder is a good example.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Bull blood sugar sort of,
you know?
Yeah,
yeah.
Well it's not,
I wouldn't say low blood sugar because
there's a lot of like fitness going on
there.
Boulders.
One of the fittest towns in the world
per capita,
like a lot of people have low body fat.
They're hiking all the time looking
people and they're in a fantastic
environment like as far as like the,
the,
the natural beauty of the land around
them and they take advantage of it.
They're always hiking and biking and
shit,
but you don't have to worry about things
like,
you know,
like my friend who grew up in the hood
said that he would,
he knew,
he knew when something was about
to happen and I said,
what do you mean?
He said,
the air changed and your friends might
be an idiot.
No,
no,
no.
He said,
he said he's no,
he said,
because what happens is it all fairness,
a lot of your friends are idiots.
No,
no.
He,
he,
he grew up in the hood and he said he
had a lot of his friends can't guy black
guy hit a lot of his friends killed.
And he said,
what I would notice and everybody would
notice is that when the shoot I was
about to happen or a fight was about the
breakout,
he said there was almost like this,
like whatever it was imagined or not,
there would be this calm before the
storm,
the air would change,
things would settle and then boom,
something would happen.
And he said everybody felt that.
And he said,
cause we were talking about how my
friend walked through the Savannah with
his wife who grew up in Kenya and his
wife knew everything about it.
She was like,
don't worry about the lions.
She knew everything.
She knew animal behavior until she saw
what animal,
what guess hyenas.
Nope people,
nope.
Monkeys.
Water Buffalo.
Ooh.
And she looked at her husband,
he said,
climb that tree right fucking now.
And he said,
I knew when she told me to climb the
tree cause there were lions.
And she said,
don't worry,
when she's had climbed the tree,
I climbed that fucking tree because it
was a water buffalo.
She knew her environment and just like
he,
he would walk through the hood and he
was safe.
He knew it,
he knew how to navigate,
but he also knew when something was
about to happen.
There's a great Jim shockey show,
Jim shockey's,
this really famous conservationist and
big game hunter from Canada.
Really interesting guy,
but he's got this great show called
uncharted.
And,
uh,
it's kind of a hunting show,
but not really.
It's more of an exploration of culture
because he travels to all these
different countries and he really gets
deeply embedded in their country and in
their culture.
And it goes to these strange lands in
the middle of nowhere in Russia and or
in Soviet Union were former.
So,
um,
and uh,
he,
he spent a lot of time in Africa as
well.
Like he's done a bunch of shows in
Africa.
Like,
uh,
they actually brought him in to kill
crocodiles that were killing people in
this village and the people in the
village,
man,
it was fucking horrific.
You would you would,
they would go through this village with
cameras and people would be showing
like,
this guy's missing an arm.
This guy is missing a leg.
This guy has a bite taken out of his
head.
Like everyone,
all these p,
everyone knew the water down there.
Everybody knew it while they were there,
while they were there filming this,
a woman got taken away by a crocodile
while.
I mean,
it's just a constant,
God terrifying and they were not scared
of anything.
Like they were scared of buffaloes.
Those fucking Cape Buffalos Water
Buffalos they're like these God damn
things.
He's grass eating monsters because they
have to fight lines all the time.
So they're just there.
They fuck.
And they fight lions off and they're
just jack to the tits.
I mean,
if you look at it and be like,
what does that thing eating?
It must be eating like steroids and they
weighed 300 pounds on the fucking
enormous.
They're enormous.
They're huge.
Lion Lions are the biggest assholes
because they'll eat their balls while
they're on them.
They take that to go to the ball.
First thing they need is their balls and
their Dick.
Really?
Yup.
Cause they're behind him.
So he got one on your back and then
they're like,
hmm,
I'll go for the ball.
Well it's probably easy to tear a loose.
Right.
That's good.
Good Bite.
Good all.
It sucks being a water polo sucks being
aligned to man.
Fuck that.
Running around killing shit with your
face all day.
That's all you can do.
You don't have a store.
You know,
nature is fucking fucked.
Fuck.
Human beings have always,
it's been a constant war against nature
actually.
It's always been,
how do you harness nature and changed if
it pretty much every animal that exists,
every animal that exists,
even lions are in a constant war with
other lions.
Constant.
Like their reign of terror is so fucking
insanely brief.
They've got a couple of years where they
run the pride and then some new line
comes along and kills them.
Yeah.
Even like great bites them so fucked up
that they have there.
They're forced to leave even great
whites,
great whites.
They played.
Uh,
they had this guy,
uh,
Paul de gelder did our podcast fighter
and kid,
and he,
uh,
he ended up losing his arm and his hand
in his leg to a bull shark in Sydney Bay
in Sydney back.
He goes to punch the sharks.
Sharks are brutal.
Yeah.
He goes to punch the shark and he goes,
oh,
I don't have a hand left and then almost
died and all that.
But,
um,
he was saying having his arm,
nosy or prestige,
it's amazing prosthesis,
which can close.
And it was a carbon fiber one,
I think.
So it's like $90,000.
Whoa.
And,
uh,
and,
but he was at Australian Navy Seal Jack
Dude,
you know,
like a handsome guy and just,
there,
he was lost his arm and leg.
But,
um,
he was talking about how um,
uh,
they played,
they had,
there was an area where at least great
whites,
I guess,
bull sharks and stuff.
And they played the sound of orchids.
They played the sound of what they make
when they're hunting.
Oh Geez.
And they said that fucking sharks didn't
come near that area for six months.
They were just like,
say I'm Outta here.
And then what hunts them us.
We fuck up the orchids.
Yeah.
It's,
it's,
it's a constant battle and it always has
been.
And I always wonder like,
it's that battle.
I mean,
it's sort of necessary.
It seems like with the natural world.
I mean obviously we're striving towards
some higher state of existence.
Everyone is,
I mean,
I think that's where Buddhist come from
and meditation comes from and veganism
comes from and that doesn't have a
central nervous shooter,
Utopian ideologies and all these
thoughts about what we're trying to do
is whether misguided or not,
we're,
we're trying to strive towards
improvement.
And when the,
and that is the state of life and it's
also the state of nature.
There's,
there has to be some sort of a balance
of power with,
with animals that are herbivores and
animals that are carnivores.
Like they're talking about bringing in
cougars on the east coast of the United
States to deal with it because you have
too many deer.
Yeah.
They have too many deer,
you know,
and um,
it's a really fascinating subject
because it's a better idea than bringing
in wolves.
Well,
they're very hard to,
they tend to be wholesale with their
slaughter.
Not only that,
they,
a lot of fun killing.
They liked the fun kill.
Yeah.
They,
they do what they call surplus hunting.
That video I showed you where I shot
that deer in London,
England,
here in London.
I had an hour and a half an hour outside
of London.
You're hunting in someone's yard.
Well,
my buddy owns this giant.
My buddy,
you know,
he made a lot of money.
He said,
I said,
where's your property?
And he goes,
well,
can you see down there?
I go,
I look.
He goes,
and can you look that way?
And basically as far as I looked at it
was all his,
and he said,
by law he needs to kill 21 deer a year
on his property because the deer are
such a problem,
you know,
because there are no natural predators.
As another thing they,
they found out today,
there's an article today,
there was always these,
um,
these myths about mountain lions being
loose in England,
in the countryside.
Yeah.
It turns out it's true.
It turns out it came from a zoo that
just admitted recently that they
released these pumas.
Wow.
They released these fucking mountain
lions they had in captivity so that
people hit like their,
you know,
they'd been ridiculed like,
oh,
someone took away a big cat took away my
sheep was motherfuckers drinking.
No,
they,
they were telling the truth.
These fucking mountain lions were
released in the 1980s.
That's amazing.
The countryside in England.
Damn.
Yeah.
Just fucking crazy.
Yas Iv and all that forest.
Well,
if as long as it,
here it goes,
the beasts of Dartmore does high saying
dark,
more mystery solved as zoo admits.
It released pumas into the wild in the
1980s.
So it was one that was one of those
things.
I think it was on that show monster
quest where they were trying to puting
Raul's looking at,
oh this amazing man.
They're amazing.
And you know,
my,
my buddy has a 70 pound or 75 pound
German shepherd,
like a bite train that,
you know,
it's a complete badass dog.
And I was looking at it and if you look
at the size of that thing's headed,
maybe 75 pounds doesn't look like much
good luck fight.
And that thing off.
I've,
I've seen that thing hit a sleeve and
it's,
it's horrific how powerful their
mountain lions get up to what 150 pounds
they can get bigger than,
than twice that size.
It's rare,
but I'll also,
their cats and cats are just way more
agile.
I've got a great story about mountain
lions.
A friend of mine is a,
um,
a guide,
an elk hunting guide in Colorado and he
said that they found these tracks of
this mount line.
They have to kill a certain amount of
mountain lions.
And their property because they have
this gigantic ranch and you know,
they just,
they,
they have a certain amount of tags that
they have to fill or that they should
feel.
And um,
so you know,
they try to control the populations of
mountain lions.
So they were trying to find this
mountain line attracting,
tracking this mountain lion attract
these tracks.
And they saw elk tracks and they saw a
mountain lion tracks and then they saw
only elk tracks.
Oh.
Because the mountain lion had jumped on
the back of this fucking gigantic 900
pound bull elk and rode it for 150 yards
and then taking it down.
So this hundred and 50 pound cat,
they wound up killing had killed this,
you know,
close to a thousand pound l is unreal
man.
But when they found it,
the fucking mountain line was on the elk
and the elk was down and then,
you know,
they followed the tracks of this elk
running with this cat on its back.
I think just leaped.
I met,
imagine being something like a person,
you know,
you weigh 170 pounds.
Yeah.
Like,
like a cat,
a cat toy,
and you just decide,
oh,
I'm going to jump on that thousand pound
horse and kill it with my face.
And their canines have sensors
apparently where they can sense where
the juggler is.
They keep adjusting their grip.
Oh God.
Good God.
What's nature man?
Nature's just so creepy and it's ways of
adjusting to life.
My friend and dress Antonopoulos,
uh,
my,
my friend,
the bitcoin expert,
explain this to me.
Last weekend in Vegas,
ducks have three foot long dicks that
curl and twist because the,
the female vaginas have adapted to fight
off rape,
duck rape.
So they have these pussies that are the,
these fucking labyrinth,
this,
these twisty turny a labyrinth,
pussies.
And they can choose to let sperm in or
not let sperm in with their gigantic
labyrinth,
pussies.
And these three foot long duck dicks,
when you see a duck's Dick,
you let con that is not real.
Look at that ducks Dick.
That's a drawing.
But there's actual photograph that's an
actual photograph of a duck.
Dick.
What in the fuck?
That's like a person,
but like a 15 foot long dick.
Yeah.
Ducks are tiny man horse to dick.
Like a person with a three foot dick is
a monster.
But a duck with a three foot long dick
is totally standard as a deck.
That's a limp.
One guy's a little little deck.
He gets shamed by the other ducks.
Poor guy.
Yeah.
I mean,
duck ducks are ridiculous.
They're,
it's a fucking ridiculous animal.
I knew the ducks engaged in rape,
gang rape.
Oh,
that's all they do.
That's the only one that hung up on one.
Look how,
look how the female's vagina has sort of
adapted to deal with the male raping.
You know,
created these bizarre pathways in their
pussies.
Wait,
when you,
when you listened to Dan Carlin's a
wrath of the cons are you read history,
you know,
and it was always,
here we come,
we're knocking down your walls when
we're selling everybody into slavery.
History is a,
is a,
is history of rape,
right?
So most women basically we'll,
I got shit.
Laws are coming down.
We're about to,
our men are going to be killed and we're
going to be,
we're going to be raped.
I mean it's just happened over and over
and over.
I would imagine that most of history is
a story like that.
And women were basically just forced to
be taken by,
you know,
either group of men or whatever,
just like most of animal has.
Yeah.
It's really,
really,
it's just brutal.
It's really interesting how,
how,
I guess women had to adapt and evolve
and,
and this woman wrote an article and I
came her name cause it was pretty
controversial and she said that because
you know,
so much of history,
women had no choice and they were forced
upon by men.
Uh,
one of two things happen.
First they had to find the man who was
the most aggressive and strong and who
could protect them from the other men.
So for women to be attracted to
aggression and strength is not so
uncommon.
But the other really controversial thing
she said was that there are cases where
women are turned on by aggressive sex,
you know,
being held down and all that stuff.
And it's probably the fact that they had
to evolve because otherwise they'd get
injured if they didn't get lubricated.
You know,
it's kind of like,
I,
I read that,
I was like,
well,
good luck with that.
But that was,
you know,
she was a female anthropologist.
I can't remember if fucking name,
but I was like,
well,
only that if can imagine coming out with
that article.
And,
and that's my,
this is my thesis for a in anthropology
and amherst college,
everybody.
And it's a very objective thought
process.
I mean there's,
there's evolution.
It's just an illusion.
Well,
it's called evolving,
you know,
in dealing with aggression the way the
ducks did well,
and also dealing with the natural world
that you find yourself in,
which is just filled with danger and
murder and constant warfare.
I mean,
that's,
that's what people did.
That's all people do.
I mean,
there was states of peace interrupted by
war and it states a piece,
I mean gingiss con kill in his,
his children and his armies killed 10%
of the population of the world during
his lifetime.
There is a New York Times article they
wrote where they were saying that he
altered the carbon footprint of human
beings on earth,
a measurable altering of the carbon
footprint because they had killed so
many people.
Like you could measure the difference in
the amount of people that were there
before him and after him.
By core samples.
Yeah.
Like,
well,
you know,
I mean Hitler did something similar in
the Russian countryside.
He killed entire villages because he was
trying to clear an area for,
you know,
sort of the migration of the German
peoples and the idea that,
you know,
let's get rid of these sort of people
that think and talk differently and
let's create a,
a utopia.
We'll what gingiss topcon did that was
so fucked up as he did it all before
there was even guns.
Yeah.
I mean there's doing bows and arrows.
They killed [inaudible] hand somewhere
in the neighborhood of 50 to 70 million
people while he was alive.
Well,
he said,
I think that what he said was really
neat.
I never forgot.
He said there were,
the Romans would create a wasteland and
call it peace and to an extent the,
you know,
the,
the con,
the Gaviscon did the same thing.
Well,
not only that,
what's interesting is how history looks
at them now.
And that's one of the things that Dan
Carlin was talking about.
Colin was talking about how people tend
to look in the future.
They'll look at,
and he was actually using it in,
in,
in terms of like,
would people do this with the Nazis that
they would,
when enough
time has passed,
you can say,
well,
he cleared the road for trade to the
east.
Yeah,
yeah.
You know,
what was the,
what was the silver lining in,
in massive genocide.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And that very controversial,
but of course with everything it would,
it goes back to exactly what we were
talking about.
Where,
where when you come up in the ghetto,
you might just create miles Davis.
I mean there's a lot of heartache and
terrible things and from shit is the
brightest flower,
that kind of stuff.
And once there's enough time passed,
then you can sort of look at it with
this distance and you can kind of
objectively look at it and go,
well,
you know,
here's the benefit of that.
Here's the silver lining.
Where that doesn't really hold up though
is if you look at where the bulk of
innovation and uh,
our artistic expression on a high level
came out of it came out of free
societies.
I mean,
look at what Sparta left behind,
nothing.
And look at what Athens left behind.
Look at Sparta lift behind a deep
history of warriors.
Mythologize but nothing,
you can really hang your hat on.
Another words,
story and,
and I talk about hardship and separating
the child from his mother and all that
stuff.
But you're Ron Butler,
300 and kicking people into wells.
But yes,
it,
it's,
there's a,
there's a mythology that,
a warrior ethos that you can,
you know,
kind of,
I'm a spartan,
but,
but Athens,
the Acropolis and the writings of all
the bug cracking and philosophy,
the butt fucking,
uh,
the idea of demos that democracy at
Demos,
the people,
these are,
these are ideas that still live on and
were built upon.
You know,
uh,
look at,
look at in today's world,
the amount of innovation that's coming
out of a peaceful society and a society
that respects other peoples' ideas and a
society that for the most part,
um,
at least from a historical perspective,
gives a great deal of freedom and a
benefit to those that have the guts to
come up with their own ideas.
Well,
that's the interesting aspect about what
the United States is as this experiment
in self government and what it is,
what it started off as.
What it is currently is that this is the
most recent of countries.
And it's also the one that has
overwhelmingly the most innovation,
the most artistic,
uh,
the contributions,
the pioneers.
There's so much that comes out of here.
So,
in terms of comedy film,
I mean obviously the rest of the world
has its contributions.
I'm not saying that United States is the
best.
I mean the Beatles came out of England.
There's a lot of amazing works of art
that come out of all over the world.
But this country is a hotbed of artistic
expression by far,
by far and away the biggest,
and it's the most recent now,
the oldest country that we know of,
the cradle of civilization is the Middle
East,
Iraq,
and that,
those are the townies of the world.
This is,
this is the thought that I've been
bounced around for a long time.
Like this is the reason why those places
are so fucked up is cause there's the
echoes of savages.
The echoes of these ancient people are
still in this area.
It's so difficult.
Like you got to get out of the fucking
town,
man.
You got to leave the town.
Well was he the great tragedy is that
the,
you know,
and they've done a lot of studies on why
do some nations,
why does some nations fail and why does
some nations,
uh,
become prosperous?
And you can break it down into a number
of things.
You can see the problem with the Middle
East for a thousand reasons.
We can,
again,
two and a lot of it was just a foreign
invasion and,
and foreign meddling and stuff like
that.
But how about getting his con yes.
I mean,
did what he did to bag that in 1260,
you know,
they say that to this day Baghdad maybe
still hasn't recovered from them
invading and killed.
They said that the rivers ran red with
blood and ink black ink,
like all the amazing works,
like viber is burned and everything
Islamic scholars throughout history were
like innovators.
They were like the huge contributions
math philosophy course.
And,
and,
and there are a lot of people say that
the Middle East has never even
recovered,
has never quite recovered from that.
But you know,
there are so many important things for
why a nation,
you know,
for example,
one is that your political parties that
lose live to see another day.
That is very important when you lose an
election and a lot of countries like the
hard liners,
and somebody said to me,
I said,
why are the hard liners in Iran such a
pain in the ass?
He goes,
because if they lose,
they will die.
That's a very important thing to keep in
mind.
So when you have power and your survival
depends on holding onto power,
you're going to have a secret police
that basically it's pretty brutal when
when they sniff any kind of
insurrection.
This country is pretty amazing.
What's so unique about the United States
is after the revolutionary war,
after every revolutionary war,
the country always breaks into civil war
always.
And the founding fathers had incredible
restraint and wisdom to,
to allow the election after that war to
go as it would,
they didn't resort to violence.
That's so unique in history,
but our country and the UK and Australia
and Canada and a couple other countries
when you lose is that democracy is built
on the idea that when your political
party loses you,
you lived to see another day and fight
on very important.
The other is property rights.
You'll need property rights.
The other is courts.
That means something and the other is
the scientific method.
You have to embrace the scientific
method.
A society has to say that it's not about
superstition.
This is not a theology.
Let's,
let's base reality on what you can
measure and what you can see that those
things are so fucking important.
If you don't have those,
those central principles as a through
line,
if that's not the scaffolding of your
society,
you're not going to do,
you're just not going to do as well as a
country like the United States.
You're not going to have people that
innovate because there's no fucking
incentive.
There's no incentive in it.
You're not going to benefit from it.
You could get it stolen
or you could be killed because you think
differently or all those things will
also,
you're not safe enough to innovate.
Yeah.
You don't have the ability to express
yourself.
You don't have the ability to take
chances.
Yeah.
So the irony,
the ironic thing is when you're
sensitive and nice to people,
when you're empathetic and when you're
respectful of other people,
even the ones you don't have this you
disagree with,
you make a stronger society.
The society is stronger in every way,
including militarily,
including you have more innovation with
militant,
with,
with weaponry.
And on that note,
God,
I'm smart guys.
Did you write that shit down?
Amazing.
You want to hear more?
You have your own podcast.
I got more out unpack.
And by the way,
I'm taking that podcast and the road
with a guy named Brendan Schaub.
Oh,
that's a different podcast.
Oh No,
this is,
yeah.
Yeah.
But let's talk about the fight and the
kid for a second.
Cause Brennan Brennan will beat me up if
I don't talk about this.
July 29th July till he hits me,
he strikes me with an open hand.
Ah,
he pulls my pants down and spanks me and
you know,
he could and I couldn't do anything
about it.
And I've tried.
I've tried to find him and it bothers me
cause sometimes I get jumpy with them.
I get jumpy and I'll get under hooks on
them.
And a giant,
no,
he's,
he's weird.
He's weird.
Shiny.
He I tried,
I said kind of tiny dude.
Don't use that word.
Just say medium.
All right.
Just say me kind of medium,
I guess.
I said the other day,
I said,
I don't believe you could.
I don't believe if we were to go take
them for a take down.
And I tried to do a little upper body
Greco with them.
Yeah.
And it didn't go well and I got so
flustered and hurt Mike actually tweak
my neck that I left my wallet and my
phone on my fucking car.
I let him,
he drove off Brendan's brother drive my
car and I yeah.
And Smash your phone.
Yeah.
Uh,
yeah.
I have blue been talking about that
recently,
that I think that people have a massive
owes overestimation massive of what they
can and can't do with their body.
And it's we,
we,
we hang around for any shop,
hang around,
Brennan Shop,
forget bearing to shop.
We played this video of these people
that put on these gigantic balloon suits
and let bowls hit them.
What?
You haven't seen this?
Well,
we'll end on this.
It's fucking insane that these people,
I want to say this,
but I think people have this idea in
their head that all the bolts come in.
I'm going to be fine.
I just fucking get out of the way.
You don't realize like they have,
they massively overestimate what they
can and can't do with their body,
how they move their body.
I got to see this,
by the way,
while we're watching this,
July 29th 30th Phoenix stand up live.
We're there.
We still have some tickets left.
Live fighter and the kid podcast show.
It's a show.
Me and Brendan Schaub Brennan shall be
doing new standup.
I'm very excited to watch this.
So these assholes look at this.
No.
Yeah,
the legs like say goodbye to your acl.
Look at this,
watch this.
Boom,
boom.
Oh leak.
I mean,
these are massive,
massive animals.
Bulls are so mean.
And meanwhile they just eat grass.
He looks like he's not hurt.
I wonder if bulls,
it'd be nicer if they had a stake
wait for it.
Yeah,
because he gets worse.
Like this guy,
he's like,
oh Jeez man,
this is good.
This is just,
just started.
Meanwhile,
people are laughing.
This is what people in rural
environments do.
They laugh,
they low my hands and I would never do
that fucking hair.
That guy got the air.
That gentleman got Lord.
Yeah.
That guy is fuck.
And he hit him again while he's out
cold.
I mean that dude flew through the air
flu.
Oh,
what about your legs,
Bro?
One more time.
Exactly.
Well,
it seems like that bowl doesn't have
horns.
They probably saw good morning God,
but whatever.
That's not saving anything.
I might have to do that,
but I don't have the gun.
No,
you shouldn't do that.
Well,
there's other ones.
This is one that we looked at.
They've figured out a way to do it
better.
Okay.
And the better one is a much larger ball
where you're completely encase,
then you're late.
You can't have it from you fucking waste
down because your legs are like super
flexible or a super weak.
My knees getting broken by a bull's head
and they will get Brogan bios.
So you would find the one,
yeah,
you've got the other one.
There's no,
you don't.
Okay.
Well there's,
there's other videos of them doing it
where they figure,
well,
this is,
is not safe enough.
We've got to get a much larger bottom.
It's much harder to hear the people in
the audience.
That's what happens when you get a bunch
of farmers and they're drunk and they
just want to fucking each other.
Yeah.
On the snake tip.
Well,
I don't know if they keep fucking each
other like crazy.
Those people,
there's no one around just like fucking
30 people in the town.
They're all fucking each other's wives.
Course snaking around.
Hey,
I don't think your husband's a true
Christian,
you know?
Uh,
I just see the way he talks to you and
just makes me feel terrible about it.
Oh,
I don't feel,
can you feel my mic mixing?
No.
Are you a Muslim kids got red fire?
No,
that's come.
Oh God.
I don't know.
That's so much comments like that noise
when I come,
I just go out of cow.
I'm like,
you're welcome.
This is for you.
You've earned it.
Ah,
foreign income at the same time.
My nectar.
Yeah.
Okay.
All right.
Good night.
Everybody is Phoenix Life.
Oh yeah.
Well Brian,
29 and 30th.
Brian Cowen,
Brennan Shop,
b.
R.
Y a n count is probably some asshole
pretending to be Brian.
That's b.
R.
I.
A.
N.
Is there an I probably have that problem
now.
See me an ochsner to where you're not
loving the new,
the new club.
Yeah.
Fourth and fifth is going to be great.
August 4th and fifth wheels leverage
programs opening for me.
It's opening.
Okay.
When,
what day?
August 4th and fifth.
Can you come?
Um,
let me find out.
Let me find,
I want to be,
yeah,
it could be all right.
You fucks.
See you soon.
Bye.
Okay.